hey everyone welcome to this interesting
video in javascript
the best way to master a language is by
programming in it
so in this video we bring to you six
simple applications that you can build
using javascript and all of this in five
hours if you enjoy watching such tech
videos make sure to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
so what's in store for you
we'll first create some simple beginner
level projects like the to-do list app
then we'll move on to a quiz app and
then we'll see how to build a calculator
app
then we'll move on to more advanced apps
like the weather app
the tic-tac-toe game
and finally we'll conclude the session
by creating a sneak game application
now i'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin
using this javascript css and html combo
known as call
to do application to do applications
very simple statement
this one is called
so let me go and create a new folder
[Music]
we would like to start working with the
html by constructing our css5 will be
well taken care of
so we say
sorry
here we
now inside this
we would like to have some header
portion
okay let me see another tip type
and insert a step type let's say div
id
equal to
this box
okay and again
now here after that
we will like to use the h2 type
textbox
input
text
id equal to
item
and
please hold it equal to give anything i
am saying
title
okay and close this
next we like to use the spam tag
and this is spam i'll say
one click
equal to
now
i do not have the function name called
new element but you would like to create
it
new element
okay and
class equal to
given i'm saying at
is also getting closed
so after the div tag you would like to
use the
[Music]
the first item
like that i can have some other items
with me
play games
walk with the dog like that i can have n
number of tasks which is available to me
okay so here the human tech is getting
closed
and the div tag is also getting closed
that's it
okay
so i do not have a css file with me so i
can just create
css
and this i like to import it
here
okay so i can have
very simple looking field for title
nothing is there
add
which must be a
kind of a button for me or whatever it
is
so it is just a span tag for me
on which i will try to click and perform
some action remember this is not my
button
now here once it is ready i would like
to go ahead and talk about my
main css which will help me to make
the complete look and feel more better
okay
thank you
so we're going to start working with the
css now
from my css
we want to basically perform
the edit where
close button i want to create it
and i want to create a close button to
hide the current list items in multiple
activities i have it which i want to do
it with my css let's get started with
css now and with my css i would like to
create some
basic effects toward my application
fine so step number one i would like to
say a strict
for everything that means for everyone
i'm saying box sizing
border box
basic one
nothing is affected because for common
for all
here i would like to start with my body
now
body
background color
background color i will say lights to
the blue
light to have taken
and
background image it's up to me whether i
would like to use it or not
but i can use
height
600 pixels
next background position
that i would like to use center
next is background repeat
because if i do not have an image i
would not be using repeat so
background
size
cover
looks beautiful
well
going ahead we talk about our container
part now
okay
so if i just see my previous code which
is there with me that is called
calculator
here in this app.css
i have a option called container
so that was my container i just copy
this
and i use it again here
here in container width i would like to
use 50 percent now
background color remain white
align cells
center display block margin
start using
120 pixels
auto and box shadow
border radius we're not using
ready once again they're not using
box shadow 5 pixel 10 pixel 20 pixels
perfect
there we go
okay
so this is my simple look now talk about
next order left
sorry border left
six pixels
t
next list
iphone
style hyphen type
i'm saying none
next party
let's take a look
better
okay
now
so
few things we've used
uh
border left six pixels solid t burning
now we talk about our ul and allied part
okay cursor
pointer next position
related
next paddle
we just would like to use the pixels
like this
background
font size
you can select 18 pixels
transition
for
0.2 seconds
for transition
okay and the last option
user icon select
none
perfect
now looks beautiful
you can see now how the effects are
awesome
okay url like that
now
we talk about our positions wise
properties ur
li colon
over
okay i said
background color
okay
and after that use your
child
order values
background color
again i can use the same
okay
now
after this
we are using this called ulli project
i'll be using background
then color
i'm using the same white
text
line decoration
which is the checked option
okay
now
after that
check before
i also want to use it so we just say
you are
checked
before
before content
after that position
absolutely that water style watercolor
sorry
watercolor i'm just using color white
then border style
solid
then bottle width
border
iphone width
bar height and width where engine 0
2 pixels
then top
10 pixels
left
pixels
then transform
rotate 45 degrees
then height
15 pixels
then width
7 pixels
now you see this now
how they work like
that javascript will be applied later on
to make it even more better so we are
just getting it ready for that
okay after that we'll be using for close
in this close using position
absolute
then write
zero
ready
four options we are using it here
okay then afterwards
close
or
and just close over and be using
background color
that's called
header
header will be using background color
t
then padding
30 pixels
and 30 pixels
color
looking beautiful
well this is your header what we have
written it now
after we will be talking about foreign
content
and then display
table
after that clear
both
header after
okay
now after this will be using for the
input
not
dot i'll be using rather using directly
input
no
then border radius
zero
then width
75 percent
then padding
two pixels
okay then float left
the next option will be font size
i'm using 16 pixels
perfect
nice
so this is my text box
okay
now we like to talk about buttons
it's time to talk about code buttons
will be saying
so
once again the conditions that will be
remain same
we talk about call
padding 10 pixels
we say 25
we say background
purple
then we talk about call color
okay and we use float
left
after this fourth left on what texturing
center
then font size
the top work on 16 pixels
then talk about cursor
will be pointer
when we talk about transition
here we talk about
that's it let's check
awesome
so you see now how exactly is it now
so my to-do list css part is over okay
well after this
we're going to talk about our gs file
which is on the most important area of
your code
now here let me close down everything
and start creating another file here one
is called
app.js
the main calculation goes here
so from this point onwards we would like
to start working with a property
whichever we have created here
on the top of that will be start working
here
okay
so in my css what are the things are
required
that you want to understand okay so we
talk about option called i like i stand
for what just items
so
let's start working with
which element i want to create
forward slash
equal
close
after that
expand
dot
open change
txt
and
so the first function which we have
written
okay
so there's a name
called node list it's just a typical
logic in fact i would not even say the
function is just a logic which you write
after that
what we need to do now is
um we have to start working with our
option called r
close
equal to
document dot get eliminated
i
function
and now here we save our
div equal to
this
dot
parent
element
display
okay
and now
next thing so this is for when you try
to click on a close button to hide the
current list item okay
current
test
okay
now
next what we could develop the code is
is to basically add a check symbol okay
while clicking on the list item that
means if any item that you basically
click so what should happen now
so when i so it will get strike saying
that hey this task is over now so we can
say bar
list equal to
okay
and then i need to write what function
which takes even as a parameter
okay here i see this
dot
target
check
okay and what should happen now
but before that
i just need to check the condition for
if
eb dot target dot tag name this way
give it a target dot
dot
false
that's it
okay now you have to basically go and
create one of functions for this
so after that i'm going to create a new
function function
dot
create element
which is
input value
equal to
document
dot
get element by id
item
dot
okay
and after that we're just calculating
this value is saying
like this
and here we see
if
input value
equal to
blank nothing is there
then what
so in such cases we can say alert
this is basically the validation for me
this field cannot be empty
okay this field cannot be empty so this
is the first error procedure showing
that else condition
in else condition it is a document
dot
get element by id
okay which is a type of item
okay so
taking a particular item which is a type
of
so else condition which is saying
document element by id
rather than item let's pass list here
and inside this list will say
otherwise what would happen
we will talk about this option called
talking element by id item
item dot value
equal to black
okay that's the case now
after that it will start working with
our
span tag now
the span tag will have its own
condition
okay so here's what's trending
dot
create element of type 1
expand here
so
after this expand we'll be talking about
our next feature now so this
after this is span
will be
yeah so we're now talking about call var
txt
equal to once again
document
dot create text
we talk about view
so
after
append child
dot open child spine
and then last but not least we have to
basically i treat to all
for
i equal to zero
i is less than
close dot
length
and
i
plus plus
then close
of type
i
you're passing it dot
on click equal to
function
and here it is
equal to
so
so friends we are almost ready now
because our javascript file is ready
after that we'll be talking about how to
include it in html to take a look well
everybody so we are all safe now since
we have our application ready with me js
really sees this will be now in our
index.html file let me just check
how to apply
this js within my code now so in my
index.html
that's it
okay and let's check about my final
outcome
okay so you can see now the crossbar
automatically appeared
okay with my application let me try to
add another one that is called
add another
it's also working
delete it
click it again it is unchecked for
unstriped
so guys that's it so
we are happy like finally we have
finished one of our very important
projects which is called to-do
application okay so this time we're
gonna develop another very interesting
example
using this html
javascript and css together and that is
called working with a quiz application
so one of the very very interesting
projects will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all i'm going
to give the name called
html quiz
now i'm going to create a three files
inside this number one i'm going to say
index.html
then i need another file that is called
app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
dot js
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first
so we'll go to the html and see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards dev tag
so within my tab tag
we would like to create
another div tag
okay
so the first top-level class
to this particular tip
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so you see
the class equal to container
now we have got another tab tag inside
this we will set them
id equal to question hyphen container
question iphone
container so that is the name or id of
this tab
and we say class
equal to height
now within the step tag
we would like to offer some details
but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tab tag here
and just have id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes you're just creating
it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this dev tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer few people
like to offer few buttons now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer one
answer once
so that i can have this button class
copy it three more times
and now we can change the names to
two
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us
dev tag is getting closed here another
tip tag is getting closed here
and now here
before that last step tag is getting
closed we would like to create another
div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's another tip tag so under this div
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start iphone btn
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
btn
space
btm
and we say start here
now just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so
rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next iphone button
next hyphen button
btn and we will give additional property
called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s capital
and
next
two buttons we have created
after this
div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
tab tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span
and here we will say span
id equal to
right hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so
after that a dip tag is getting closed
and
that's it
and it lasts
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this drive tag i would like to close
even before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip tag which is closed
at the end
and here we want to include the script
tag
script
src equal to
script.js
that's it our html page is almost ready
let's review
and
yes i can see some standard buttons has
been created
now we would like to look make gives a
better look and feel to this kind of
buttons and
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a route
and with this route some basic settings
we are offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
hue
hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral
the value is giving a score 200
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen
q
again
hyphen rom
this value we're giving us
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hyphen hue
thus we are making with the variable
hyphen f1u
neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is margin
module will also remain zero after that
display
after that not display i would say
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we are providing width almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contents i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
and this will we would like to use this
var
again this in this world we are using
hyphen hyphen q
and followed by
comma
these things and this is style we
wouldn't we would like to use in my
index.html page
so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
define the styles we always use
link
css
so the value is automatically style.css
but we would like to change to app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body dot
correct
body dot correct
we are providing
you
and here we would like to offer
iphone iphone draw
and also sorry not wrong just for
correct
and
we can use
body
dot wrong
body.com
so same thing i'd like to copy
so rather than saying correct
using
rock
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
container inside my container i would
like to offer with
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80 percent
now going forward background color
background color we are offering white
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box shadow we can say 0
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now
we would like to offer the buttons
here in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so
dot
btn
hyphen grid
well
in index.html file
so we have a call button grid this
button grid we would like to start from
here
btn grid bit in grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying 2
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then 0.
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like it
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot btn
followed by the details so
iphone open hue
var
will be using neutral
okay
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and
hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
were
hyphen iphone u
followed by
okay so these are the values for border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so
in background color we will just use hsl
rather than this
so hyphen hue
and 50
percent okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding
just 5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button over
dot
btn dot
or
over
and for this performer
you want to say border color
this watercolor you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well so
this is how my
initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use
dot
start
hyphen btn
and also for
dot
next hyphen pt
common look and feel for both
one size
one
dot five
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give bold
followed by padding
this padding is be like 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls reset display
flex
followed by justify contents
just justify content services center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display
none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start directly the
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const
and here we will say
start
button
equal to
document dot
get element by id and here it will give
the name
call start
hyphen vtn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like
here
another one
here we change the name
and give the name called
question
container element
container
element
question container element documentation
by id
here we give the name called question
hyphen container
question hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called question element
question
element documented element by id here
will be passing question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers
or i can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shovel question because we
want every time the questions to be get
shuffled
shuffled questions
current question
index
shuffle questions and current question
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
first question which i would like to
create it here it's called question
now here we will say
javascript framework
so which of these
is it
which one of these i would say which one
of these is a
javascript framework
this is my question now
okay so i would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i see text
first will be python
python
okay
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so
i can say true
last i'm keeping it's called
false as usual
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create a few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers
so i just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who is the prime minister of india
so we can have two
answers available
okay
talk about kundalini removing value is
called what true
second we're going to give the name
called
this value is called false
so taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 multiply by 3
i can have many answers
so i'm just making the first is called
six
which is false seconds 12
like that total we have created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer
one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be known score clear
status class
function
player
status
class
it takes some parameter call element
and here we will say element dot
class list
remove
element.classlist.remove
correct
and once again i copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
called what
right
and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached
there's only one function we've attached
that's called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
call
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second is called correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by we are saying if
correct
then
element
dot class list dot
add
correct
okay
else
use the same option
but we'll try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use
const
select selected button
selected button equal to e dot
target
number one second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
data set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this
set status class function
in the set status class we'll be passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and
correct
is the second parameter
okay now we're using
array
dot from
and here in this editor from we're using
answers
button element
dot
children
okay followed by
dot
for each here
we're using
this button
as in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called
set status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button
dot
data set
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the
main evaluated value called if
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current question index
plus 1
then what
then we are saying
next button
dot
class list
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot
class list
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
call if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then quiz score
plus plus
and
document dot
get element by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by
dot inner html equal to
quiz
score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
dot
class list
add
height
okay
now
we are using this while option now
answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we'll be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is
something which we wanted to start with
okay
well
reset state is already set
now going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
in a text
equal to
question
dot
question now followed by questions dot
answer
question dot
answers
dot
for each and here i would like to use
your passing word
answer as in parameter
now
here we like to create a button called
const
button equal to
document.
get sorry document.create element
i'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you to set the value
equal to
answer
dot
text
then
followed by button dot
classless
dot
at here we are
offering
btn
okay now we are saying
if the condition is
answered dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
dot
dataset
correct
equal to
answer dot
correct
okay
now the next thing is we are using
button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer button element
dot
append child
of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say
function set
next question
here
function
set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state
the function we are calling it and
saying question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is what the sect
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal to
we have called questions
dot
sort
okay here we say
math dot
random
and
five
are passing this value
okay
after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are given 0 right now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
class list
remove
height
okay
and then
we're calling
set next question
which is a function we are calling it
initializing our quiz score
with the value called zero
well start game is
ready
next thing which you to start the cover
button
so here we are saying
start button
dot
add event listener
here
in this
on my click event
i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next we'll be calling
next button
dot
add event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we are calling current
question index
current question index
plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be
kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so
our javascript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with us
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like it
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react
now you can see it's automatically
making rest of them as a
red and not giving me the next button
now
the prime minister of india i'm saying
modi
great next
and i say
for multiply by 3a12 i said next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask as a flask it says twitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how
dear friends your project is now
completely working
and expected as the way it was designed
for when i
once again restart and you can say start
button that is giving me four multiply
by three that means it is one second
have taken
random question so we have decided to
basically develop another very
interesting project in javascript that
is known as calculator application
like you've seen earlier some projects
like in tic-tac-toe you talk about snake
game you talk about quiz application
this time we're going to introduce you
another very interesting project using
this javascript html css
so called calculator application
so let's get started let me try to
delete first those files which we really
do not need it now
uh
we delete those all
yeah now i'll be creating a new folder
now and give the name called
calculator app and in this calculator
app once again we need some new files
which is called index
dot html
and we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is called app dot
js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html file where we will be
creating a template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a god body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator
so that will be my h1 heading
after that we will start working with
the div tag
now within this div
i would have to create lot many classes
i may not have lot many css classes but
we can give some classes here so we can
say class equal to
container
okay
so within this div tag we're going to
create a table now because i want to
organize it
so starting with the table within this
table
tr tag and within this tr tag i need a
td
now in this td i need few things call
call
span
equal to 3
another value
and here
i want to offer the text box
input type equal to
text
okay input text id equal to give the
name called result
that will be the final outcome while uh
pressing all the different buttons id
equal to result and
class equal to
the screen remember i haven't created
those css classes but but we're giving
some names but later on we can utilize
it while creating those css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now insert this td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here in this input text sorry i would
like to better say button because i'll
be having
buttons
okay
input
button
value
equal to
c
and
on click equal to i may not have any
function right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some domain
name here
i'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function we get
called
and after that class
equal to
clear
yeah so this is my button tag
after this our td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another table row
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here
and inside this td i'll be having
another button we get created
so i'll just say
this is my another button now input
equal to button value equal to
on click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call 1
okay and class equal to member
plus equal to
number
and here after that tag is getting
closed
okay now you have to start another td
tag here
okay like that we have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 on click product
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like
now i can see the buttons like in c one
two three but yes i'm gonna create few
more buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here
and create few more buttons so this is
where the table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this
and paste it again
i have to create
the button
like in 3 4 something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
yeah
i'll get the value called three
so val equal to two value equal to three
display three
and then afterwards
just giving the value call
forward slash
and here also we're gonna keep the value
called forward slash
and here class equal to
operator
after that you have to do the value 4
and then followed by six seven
so here we give four
four
five
five six
six
after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about code seven
then we have to have eight
okay nine
okay after that we're giving for plus
and
display
plus plus equal to operator
operator okay so
here
you can see the table data is getting
closed and here the table is also
getting closed
and after this table row you can start
working with
another table row here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
okay
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is valid equal to
dot and here we get the value called
decimal
okay
now display 0
so after giving this dot basically take
what the value
zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have another one
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that
we'll be once again
taking this this time rather than giving
this 0
we'll be using this call as a button
and value equal to
equal
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this song will not be
passing anything
it like a normal function
and plus equal to
equal
okay
so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we'll be using
value equal to
multiplication
display
plastic
and here we'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table is
getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your div tag is also getting
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome so we have got
all those
necessary calculator behavior
which
we wanted to
reveal
okay now our next statement will be once
we're giving this c then we have a call
one two three
and then forward slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so
let me check whether we have used six or
not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so
let me go back here
4 5 6 let me copy this
and paste it later
before
minus
six
equal to
number
okay so we're almost set now
so we are having this
look and feel
in this way giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then plus related behavior so we are all
set now and after that we'll be
basically applying the css as well as
the javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
this outlook is looking properly or not
see what my expectation is after one two
three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next and then
seven eight nine and again forward still
but i can think this is absolutely
unorganized
so after this when we say
this forward slash which we have used
after heisen
okay your td is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start
another tr here
okay
so that i can put them into the another
level now so under this tr i can use
this td now so after this minus
after four five six
minus once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
starting another tier after that we talk
about seven eight nine
okay plus
see here talking about seven eight nine
plus here the table is getting close and
it is starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which i
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it later on
okay because you can see eight is
missing right now
so here
seven
copy this
equal to eight
eight
multiplication
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel
so i need to go ahead and use what css
because without css i really can't
utilize this in a proper way so i have
to start working with a css friend now
in css front how to start first we will
go back to my code and here in my css
we'll start working with
font family but before font fabric i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using called t
that looks nice
okay so
i will be using this app.css
in my html to see the look how it has
been appeared right now so in my
index.html file
on the top under my head section
link
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css
you want to use
some h1 color tool so here
we would like to use the h1
texture line
center
color
white
margin top
margin top we'd like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement will be called the screen
so we say towards
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
background color gray
and after that border
sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
okay then padding
you would like to save 10 pixels
and then
margin
say auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want that's for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me
and rest of the details we'll be showing
you one by one and now we'll be talking
about call input
okay
input
type
equal to button
for input type equal to
button
okay
input application button of type
over the model over on my button i say
background color
change to what
right what else i can say
let's walk
okay
and
when the button is active
what i want
let me copy
and put a little button and here i say
active
and this color should be orange red
like this
you can see now how it is basically
looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about call
operators
operator should behave different so i'm
saying dot
operator
in this operator we say background color
background color orange
okay then padding
i want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using cold border
sorry
that border
i'm using this called solid
and then black
after this a bit
using 100
then height
height is 40 pixels
orange color
and
you can see the moment you take
microsoft returns to white
perfect and now those were type number i
also want to change them
so for number
then i need height
of type 40 pixels
then i say color
it looks i want to say called black
then border
border we want solid
black into excess solid
black
and cursor
once again
decimal i need to have a different
options with me
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it
does it
so for decimal background color will be
light blue
padding five pixels color black border
solid
okay black two pixels
percent height forty pixels five cursor
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light blue
now
i talk about
clear okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color
background color is changed to light
salmon
line segment
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width 100
height 40 pixels
fine so cursor
pointer
file margin
auto and margin bottom
merging bottom differences
let's check
perfect now it looks beautiful
okay
now
here
after giving these details we're talking
about called equal part dot equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so we recall
background color id color
and
after this
since it is equal so we say padding 5
pixels is ok color black fine border
fine with 100 height 40 pixels
color and cursor pointers just
in this container width i want 40
percent
white
okay
now
here
padding is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all you've got width
you see
display block
which we're taking margin
okay in margin
to pixels
auto
okay now align cells
go to
center
okay border radius
border radius which is say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
box shadow 5 pixels
black
and body
so these are details i have it now okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell display block border radius
padding no no
writing 15 pixels we've given audi i
don't need to give it again
margin
okay fine
box shadow let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay so this is where exactly my
application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 percent we're taking background
color
let's bring it below
then align cell
display block
okay margin
okay
and uh border radius
and uh
fine i think we're all good now
so
that's it so we'll try and implement the
javascript part well everyone so our css
file is ready our html is ready it's
time to just uh
go ahead and talk about my
final question that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators now here i just say function
display
function display which takes
val as in parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result
okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay there's a function
after that we have another functions
available here called function solve
here
we just use the value called
x equal
to document dot get element by id
result
okay
dot
value sorry
value
okay and say connect
y
equal to
perform the calculations for the using
one function called
eval
and type
access and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document.
get it involved
result
dot
value equal to
y
okay
now
later on
i'll like to use another function here
function
clear
screen
and here we say
document dot
get it in my id
here we say
result
dot
value
equal to
like that
so clear screen
solve
and
display three functions are associated
with me and these three functions
are the part of this javascript file
which i'll be calling it
at the end before
the water tank get closed so here
script
equal to
f
x
that's it okay let's try to execute now
here
two you can see the values
i will say plus
six
equal to eight absolutely otherwise say
c let's clear the screen
six
divided by
two
equal to three awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is the css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in of this template
beautification and here last year for gs
which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay
hello everyone and welcome to the
another very exciting project for our
development in javascript that is known
as call weather pro it is in the
continuation to the series of the
previous project what we have developed
in javascript and this is once again a
very competitive project i'm going to
present to you
which is called weather pro where i
would like to offer you the real-time
weather application into your browser
taken from the real-time weather
applications
okay so let's get started with the new
development of our application which is
called a weatherproof
now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more kind of static in nature where like
you talk about snake game you talk about
tick tock toe or other type of games
like an online quiz
where the data was very much static in
nature but we were presenting the data
in the form of more dynamic in nature
this time
this project we are presenting you while
connecting with a real-time weather
application where i'll be making a one
rest api call or else you can say
asynchronous call and since javascript
is working as a what appear asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the javascript can communicate with your
backend load the data and represent the
records in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this
vs code editor only just to
develop our code and once again
for developing our presentation part
we'll be using html for
formatting part we'll be using css and
to make some dynamic update we'll be
using javascript now here i'm going to
create a new file name called index
dot html apparently i just want one more
that is called app.css
and another file we need it
and
that is called
your js file so we're saying
app
dot gs5
so total number of three files are
available to us i'll start working with
an html now and here
we'll start
with this html templates
now here first of all i would like to
load my css file which i do not have
right now but certainly i can use it
okay so i can just say link
area equal to
style sheet
and href
equal to
app dot css
well that is my css location
now i just want to create
some
this link area i would better use
inside my head tag that will be the more
convenient place
now in my body
i want to have some of the div tags and
there i can decide where the weather to
be displayed so i can just start with my
div tag now
with my div tag i say
class equal to
i can just create a class which later on
i can offer
a different size of or different type of
style so we can say container
so we're saying div class equal to
container now within a div tag we like
to use another div tag which is a nested
one
so this step will have another class
called
class equal to
app hyphen
title
i have hyphen title
in the same div tag we can use
that's a typical paragraph tag
and here we say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag
we want to have a text box because i
would expect a client to enter the
detail on which city or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
sub properties like id
equal to
search
second type
equal to
text
next placeholder
equal to
enter
the city
next
autocomplete i'm saying autocomplete off
the reason because i do not want the
previous value user can see in this case
we can say autocomplete
off i do not want any autocomplete in
this
okay
now
here it is getting close now
after that we also want the locations
for that i may use some of the png files
and all but right now i just want to
display the details
of the user
like which city he belongs to and
accordingly i can display the records
right in your application
so for that i really need some of the
div tags once again where i can display
the details
of this particular city so i'm just
having this only text box let me go and
go back and check
how it looks
so i have a call enter the city so here
i'll be picking up the city and
somewhere down the line i have to
display
the record so
after this div
we can also have some of the locations
to be displayed
so
we can just use the notifications
and
also the location where you want the
details to be displayed
okay so we can use div class
class equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so div plus equal to temperature
hyphen value inside this i'll be using
paragraph tag
and here in my paragraph i'll say iphone
and
this degree centigrade or whatever you
want to display it here
and we'll use
a spandex within this and show
in degree centigrade
that's it
and if you want to define the
temperature description
after this div tag we can use another
day of tag
and inside my dip tag
i can define the temperature description
okay so we can say tip
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
and within this i will be using what
a paragraph tag here i'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which i want let me check
okay so it's here right now
so now let me try to collect the value
from the client and perform some
javascript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the css features
inside my code now
now few things i would like to say is i
have basically downloaded some fonts
which i would like to use it in my
application and i also have some of the
icons which i would like to use
during my application presentation so
there are some png files out there which
i have downloaded from the internet just
to bring more beautiful experience
towards my application development
well this is another background image
which is called bg.jpg which i would
like to
make it as a background of my
existing
application so i'll start with my css
and see how this css can really bring
some new features to my code well
first thing i need to have a call
forward face so to make this font face
we are using this statement name called
here at the rate
font face
and
i like to use font family
font family i'm using
mod select
okay
it is already there with me monster it
and the url
what is looking forward for so we are
saying src
url
and i'm saying under the
font so we have a file called ttf
okay that is called bolt.ttf that is the
file which is there
next thing
so
for every
location i want to use the font family
font iphone
family i want to use same
monster
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
i need url
and in this url we can say
bg.jpg
in my background
next thing is background color
that i needed steel blue
then i need height
i'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
this i needed is center
next is your background repeat
i say no repeat
next is your background size
this i'm saying cover
this is my body part
okay let's check
okay
looks awesome now you see this now this
is how
my weathering was looking like it you
can see like the background looks
awesome now now
next thing we required a container
so we are saying
dot
container
container we say width
width 50 percent
next background color
we're just using white
next we need it is your align itself
that will be
center
display
will be block
margin
so in margin we can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius we're saying 10 pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box should be giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my
container so index.html file we have
called container
now
okay looks awesome now
so this is where exactly the details
will be
okay
now
after this css
container we have used
we can talk about called title
you can say
hyphen
title inside this we will say width
will be 100
then height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
then we need display
display we need flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying center
next we need justify content
that will be the justify content which
is center
then flex direction
would be column
so this option we're using for our tool
name called what
app hyphen
title
okay so here in my index.html file we
have called give class equal to what i
have hyphen title
equal to weather info let's check
okay
so
this is another
we have used that is called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph
so here
this app title
tab title is space p
but it should be the class so we are
saying dot
and there also we have to use what
dot because both have to be the class
type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference i forgot to add
dot and now you can see it looks better
comparatively
paragraph
so once again in my paragraph i'll be
having texture line
center padding
i want 15 pixels
then i need margin
margin would be 0 and
auto
followed by font size
font size
this i'm saying score 1.2
here
this position then color
we are giving
hash
value
call 333
okay
now here
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well going forward for the search
because if you remember we have an
index.html file we have a call id code
search so here in my
app.css i have to use
hash
search
okay so this search conditions i want to
use it
now inside my search i need few things
one is called display
i need block after that i need margin
left
auto
margin right
width
i'm looking forward for 5 pixels
height
that i'm looking forward for 20 pixels
then border radius
i'm looking for four five pixels
then outline
that's called none
there is a border
okay
in this bottle what we can say three
pixels
let's paste solid
okay and once again
see
that's what
let's check
so this is actually the text box
so once again search you use display
block
margin
lift auto margin right auto width 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing i said
padding should be 5 pixels
width
should be 40
that's why it is smaller but it will be
let's check
yeah let's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready i'll be
having some of the details for the
notifications also
so what i need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
now in notifications i would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving white
and after that we using display
and we are saying
no
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by
its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all we
are saying color
color
is basically red
okay or else if you want to give maroon
it will the model
and
after this
the next property we are taking is
called font size
one size we are taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is zero
after that texture
line center
adding 10 pixels
0.
so this is for notification p and then
the weather container
okay in my weather container i will say
width
hundred percent
sorry
yeah with 100 height
i'd be giving 260 pixels
or if to you 250 pixels if you want
background color
this background color we are giving is
called once again white
and followed by margin top
20 pixels
pixels this is for weather
container now for the weather icon
weather hyphen
icon
i am saying
width
is 100
and height
128 pixels
just to give in a better look
now the next thing we're using dot
weather
icon icon
space img
here we can display
none and
sorry display note none i will say
another block
display block and margin
giving 0
space auto
there's for
i and location icon if i want to give
then
location iphone
icon
this location icon i can save with same
width height
so
width i'm giving is 100
then
height i'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option called
padding
then take pixels
so it's for location icon
now
followed by location icon we are also
giving call location icon img
okay dot
location hyphen
icon space img
here we are giving the value called
display block
display block width
we're giving is called 32 pixels
and then we're looking forward for
margin
margin would be 10 pixels
and
auto
then cursor
so cursor will be pointed for sure
and then we required padding
padding looking forward for 5 pixels
followed by border
border we are looking forward for steel
glue
steel blue
solid
and 2 pixels
then border radius
border
radius
we're looking forward for 10 pixels
and followed by your color
so these are the look and feel we have
to basically offer it for my
current application which i yet to
discuss in my
next development
then i'll be having some small small
properties here
okay
and those properties are nothing but to
give you the details of
like
temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen value
okay this temperature hyphen value we
can give it
is 100
and height
we're giving this call 60 pixels
okay this is for temperature value let
me copy this again
and
i'm giving this temperature value space
paragraph
here
i'm gonna give padding
margin
then color
which color you're looking forward for
we can just say dark gray
okay for any color which you're looking
forward for it's up to you now but if
you want you can change the color also
to another one we're giving this call
hash
okay
okay that is a more perfect color for
this
development now font size
4 em
then followed by texture line
and once again center
so this is for
temperature value b
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value p
then you can use a temperature value
span
here
dot
temperature value span
space
span
and
here let me do the additional dot
now within this span
say color
once again same
and font size
this is for
span
and in the same temperature description
paragraph you can use it
dot
temperature iphone description
description space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
then margin
followed by color
same color the one which we have used it
earlier
after this color just a texture line
center font size
1.2
this is for temperature
description okay
last which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now dot
is space three
here we can say margin
then padding
then color
same color i would like to use
after this color texture line
and font size
and copy
text align center and here we'll be
giving some different value called 0.8
okay and last which is really left with
call tube
in that
relative
hair position
i'll be using
absolute
top
from top
i'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
i'm using 120 pixels
that's it
okay so all set
so you can see now
here we have to basically offer the
details how my pictures will be taken
attack so this is what my css now will
be applying some of the css into my
applying the css into my html to see how
it really looks like it if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
okay so we have seen some of the css
classes we have introduced
in my html
we have used this
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used trip class equal to temperature
value
okay if you just check carefully we have
used this temperature and there we have
used temperature hyphen
value
but before that we would like to use
some other properties too
okay after this autocomplete equal to
off we want to use
another div class
okay before my previous date tag is
closed here so here
after this we would like to use another
div tag
div
here in my tip
i'll say
class
equal to
location hyphen icon
location hyphen
icon
okay and here i'll be using img
src
equal to what under
icons i'm using the file name called
location
dot png
and alt equal to we leave it as it is
the blank
okay
now here the div tag is getting closed
now there's another div tag is getting
closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another div class for
notification here
class equal to notification
dev class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another tip for the weather
condition
another div tag and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
whether hyphen what
a condition
or i can say whether iphone container
whichever so i can say
whether hyper container
under this
weather container i like to use
another tip
for weather icon
tip for
class equal to weather hyphen icon
weather hyphen icon
and within this
i want to use another img
src equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot png
okay div tag is getting closed
so after this div tag is closed i'm
gonna use
temperature value
so the temperature value is anyways used
here if you see
raising call temperature value after the
first step tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used
after that the paragraph tag and the
temperature hyphen
description b
after the p that the div tag is getting
close
okay and after this we're using tip
class equal to location
so we want to use
div
plus equal to
location
and within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
[Music]
with this hyphen
after this paragraph exists close this
tip tag this tip tag
another tip tag three div tags are
closed
that's it and at the last
before my body tag is closed
i would like to use
script
src equal to
app
dot
js
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now
so
this i
want to be display only when i don't
find the weather and the location
anymore so look and feel is absolutely
good and now i'll start working on my
javascript front
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our javascript code
so in this javascript code first of all
i need few things
first thing what i need is called
individual elements or individual
properties of my application i need cost
icon element
i can element equal to
document dot
query selector
and i'll be using the name
call
dot
weather hyphen
icon
okay
now
copy this
now we will call icon element
location
icon
here we are saying
dot location
hyphen
icon
now
next
i need is called temp element
here using
the property call dot
temperature hyphen
value
space
p
next we're looking forward for
dec element
which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyphen
description
hyphen
temperature has been description space
got
then location element
okay we need location element and we use
dot location
space b
next we need notification element
notification element and here we're
going to keep the call
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements
next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this is statement is all about
selecting the arguments the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying var
input
equal to
document dot
get element by id you'll be given the
name called
search which is the name or id of my
text box let
city equal to
blank
next we're going to keep score let
latitude
equal to 0.0 we are initializing this
value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input fields
next we want to apply the events here we
are saying input
the variable
dot
add event listener
the variable what we're talking about
which even list will be talking about
key up
key
up
and what even do you want to apply so we
are saying
function
with a parameter name called what
event
and now we would like to attach the
logic now
we send if
what is the condition
event
dot
key code
equal to
okay
then
that means number 13 is basically the
enter
see the key code means for 13 13
represent the enter keyword so even dot
key code equal to what 13 so here
same event
dot
preview
default why we're using this because i
do not want my page to be get
refreshed just to avoid this we're using
this and after that we are saying city
equal to
input dot
value
now
you will be using this another function
because i do not have function created
otherwise i have to call the function
name called get search weather and be
passing this as a parameter so we are
going to get
search
whether i do not have this function i
yet to create this
and pass it here as a what
city
and we say
console
dot
log city whatever we are basically
printing it
okay
so that is the first thing
later on we need to get the data so to
get the data we are just using this
variable name called const
weather
equal to
const weather equal to
curly braces
after that we are saying
weather
dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want i'm saying unit
of type what
celsius
i wanted a celsius put it in a double
quotes
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in kelvin i'm saying
const kelvin
equal to value of the kelvin is about
and after that
go on c ultimately what we need is
we need to interact with our backend api
from where i will
get or receive the updated weather
applications
okay
now
to get this i'll be using one very
popular api here that is called
openweathermap.org
this is a very very popular app
which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear
so here
what you can do this
open method map.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular
unique
api key
since
as a visitor you really can't get it
unless you register yourself so i have
my api key with me so i'll go here
it'll ask me for the registration
so
i already signed up so if you're not you
need to sign it there's an api key for
me which i need to copy and this api key
i'll be using it in my project
so i just use this property called const
key equal to
to paste my key here
okay
after this paste in the key but make
sure that you rather using my key you
use your key otherwise this application
sometimes won't work
so i'm basically trying to use this tool
name called geolocation
i'm saying if
geolocation
okay again
navigator
navigator is you know there's a browser
object model element
so here we are using
navigator
okay
navigator dot
geo location dot
get current position
in which i'll be passing the first
parameter name convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case
if any error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
i'm using this statement name call
notification
element
you see this notification element dot
style
dot
notification remain dot
get elements by class name
but i don't need this rather i will use
what the style
dot display equal to
block
then i will be using the same
notification element dot
inner html equal to
you're gonna use a paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
so you have to enable the current
location of yours
okay that's where exactly
so after that we have to basically set
what the user position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location we'll be just using another
function here
function
set
position
it will i'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position dot
chords chords for coordinate start
latitude
okay like that
longitude
equal to
what position dot
cords
dot
longitude
after this we'll be using this function
called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon seen
i'll be having it defined below but as
of now we are just saying
get weather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this function name called
what
set
position
in which will be passing all the values
okay at the same time
i will be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
i would like to use location
icon the one which you define on the top
card
add event listener which even listener
i'm saying
one click
second
function
which take
even doesn't parameter
and inside this i'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey
just
and
we say get weather
okay once again you'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same i just copy
this
and paste it here
okay everyone so we have written till
here when i try to run my browser
so i should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined
but obvious because this message what
we're writing it here is called show
error
okay this
as a function as a parameter it is not
defined let me define this function
called show error so we are saying
function
show error which take
error isn't sorry just take
error is in parameter
now in this we are using
notification
dot
style
dot display equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element
dot
inner html
equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
error
dot
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and now
see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if i say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment i click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because i told you
this get weather function i need to
develop so i get to develop this
function called get weather but before
that i'm using another function called
function
get search weather
get
search weather in which i'll be passing
what
city name
now
what exactly my apa will be in case if i
want to make a call i will be using let
api equal to
now the url will be what
http
colon double forward slash api dot
open
weather map dot
org now open weather map dot org
slash
data
slash two point
sorry two point
five that is a version slash
weather
okay question mark
i have to take the city dynamically so
i'm saying weather
question mark q
equal to
here
we're using what city
and
we're using ampersand
app id
equal to the one app id we have used it
already
okay what is that
that key
so that is the key
which you've already written that app id
we are passing it right over here
okay q equal to city and applied equal
to this
now after that to make the restful api
call i'll be using one independent or
by default api which is available to us
that is known it's called what
fetch
okay so if you just check this
fetch it is basically a take requestion
form
and give you the what a promise response
so return type will be the promise type
in this fetch i'll be passing what
the api
and will be using dot
then that means if the request
is successful using function
function
response
then function is in parameter response
we are saying let
data equal to
response dot i'm expecting the responses
type of what json
using json now and return what
data
so it will be returning data back to me
now
if it is successful then what then i'm
saying dot then once again it is
chaining
again
function
data is in parameter
now in this case we'll be getting lot of
things i'm saying
whether
okay dot
temperature it's a predefined dot
value
equal to i'm using what
math
dot
floor inside this we are passing what
data dot
main
dot temp it is a predefined property we
are receiving it now hyphen
kelvin whatever the kelvin value is
basically we are taking score 273 on the
top
minus
kelvin
followed by
another property what
weather dot
description
equal to we're using
data
dot
weather zeroth position because it
contains a lot of data but i will be
taking what
description out of that
then
weather dot
icon id
whether dot icon id equal to
data
dot
weather
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather dot
city
okay equal to
data dot
name after this
weather dot country
dot
equal to
data dot
sys dot
so these are the properties i have it
right now with me
okay and once i received all the
property i'll be using dot
then
i will be using one function
and i will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but i'm gonna say
there's a one function name called
display
weather
this function i had to write
but this function just putting it here
okay
now this is closed
after that
since i need to get a weather from the
apa provider
so i have to also password the latitude
and longitude which i am receiving it
from the client because
here i just want to have two things
the properties as well as whether both
and both i'll be using it one by one
okay so here
we have kept this get search weather and
now i'll be calling one more function
after this logic and i'm giving the name
called function
getweather
okay it takes two parameter one is
called what latitude
and thing is called
longitude so we have two things called
latitude and
longitude
and here i'm using this property called
what let
api equal to
once again if you remember
i have used this statement i'll just
copy the same
and
pass it here
but challenge would be this time
i will not be passing city name because
the two options are available either you
type the city name or else you click on
the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this feather question mark
here i will not be using q i'm using
what
led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using
and
hello in
equal to
we're using logitech
okay and app id equal to what key so
this is the variable which we have it
now
okay
now similar thing which we have used it
on the top
okay called fetch api
so i just copy this same fetch api again
because i really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code when we
know it very well it can be similarly
done i just copy and
paste it here
so the same fetch api
dot then response data equal to response
or json return data then
whether that temperature method flow
says country dot display weather so we
have used the same thing here and after
that we have to use the last function
here that is called display weather
display
weather
and here in my display weather i can use
what
i can element dot
i'll be using
img
src
equal to
icons
slash
dollar
and we'll be passing what whether
okay dot
icon id
okay
dot
png
okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot png and after that
it is closing that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
so rather than closing this i'll be
closing that and
this i'll be closing it here
now we'll be using top element
sorry temp element
template
dot
inner html
equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
weather dot
temperature
dot
value
okay
and after this value we can just use
this asterisk side
the one which i told you
okay and use
span
okay next we're using call talk element
so we have that sorry dsc element
we have got dac element dot
inner html equal to
weather dot
description
and last but not least location
element dot
inner html
equal to
what
i'll be using once again this
and here
weather dot
city
comma
dollar
weather dot
that's it these two properties we have
to use it
and we are all done
let's check
with my code
if i get any error
now
allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds globe undefined that's
perfectly fine intercity
you can see awesome beautifully it is
showing you
the conditions it's saying smoke 28
degree centigrade and
let me put another city here i'm gonna
say called
pune awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and
let's see one more
i would say
awesome and now we are planning to
develop one very special game for you
in javascript and now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known for tic tac
tic tac toe is
world's favorite game we have already
played a lot in our childhood days and
still my favorite game so i have decided
to basically offer you this tic-tac-toe
game
developed in javascript html plus css
which can create something really really
great effects for the end users so let's
go and start developing our next game
that's called tic tac toe
so in this tech tractor i will start
working with creating a folder called
tic tac and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called index
dot html
now here onwards the same thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but so we're going to create some div
tag now
so in this div tag
i'll be creating some of the tags
in which the css class will be applied
so we just gonna create a classes
uh for i'm gonna just use those classes
but we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create those so we're saying
do
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
dev tag inside this i'll keep
my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tip here we
say
h1
and inside this h1 it gives the message
called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic-tac-toe
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for player 1
or else i can say player one and inside
this let's give the name call
layer
one label is closed
and
after this label will start working with
our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to player1
next we want id
equal to
player1
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're gonna close this this is
my first text box
and um same thing i would like to create
for my another one so the first dev tag
we have used let me go and create
another tip tag
in this div tag i'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after the step
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
dev tag is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now
so here we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show some containers where the
details will be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check
whether it is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name in the name after the stick tag
tool
so
yeah so here are the details we have
taken input applicable text and input
applicable text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div
and inside this div
i since i haven't created any css
classes so those we can use it later on
but let's have
this div
and inside this div i would like to use
one more tip type
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so
in this div we can just give the value
called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value
we are passing it
the
data is equal to zero the div tag is
getting closed
fine so
that's how we want it now
so here
the first step tag is closed like that
we can create another data id so zero
one two total number of three we want to
create it so i want to create zero one
two three four five like this
so the way we have created here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
id equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
two
three
four
five so zero one two three four five dot
number five we have created
one more i would like to create it now
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
and uh
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
border button that you can basically
offer it little later on
but here
we can use one more div
and here we say do
do classical relative
and within this step tag i can use
any image type if i want
so i just leave it as it is
and after this
i can create one more div tag
and insert this another tip
okay
and
under this i'm gonna create
a button
okay and in this button we'll be having
some value
okay we can secure the value name called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
spam
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
it's just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there is no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me
more better look when your application
will start
but most importantly i need to start
working with a javascript part where the
logic will get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included the javascript with
my code
so here
i can see here
script tag
script
equal to
now file i haven't created so let it be
as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style sheet answer so
i just say
link real quick start sheet
into the name called
app.css though i haven't created but i'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our
consideration now we'll be creating this
css as well as the javascript to make
this example complete
well we are ready with our html but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js
and inside this we will start writing
the logic with our main application
okay
now the first thing is how we're going
to start now
yeah
so
first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but i can give the name called
app
which i'm going to create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i'm saying
let
gameboard
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one
more for making it nine
[Music]
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay
now this is all empty right now
after that we're gonna create let
turn
just a new variable
equal to
zero
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player itself
like which player turns it to be so just
it is trying to mention it i'm saying
let
winner equal to
false
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
how are you going to create a player we
say const
player equal to
what we're going to pass
name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
now inside this initiative
input
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id
here
we're going to take
the class name of this particular text
field so we are saying input icon
field
okay
dot
oops
okay now after this we have to say cost
address
okay
next we are saying
add
player
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
is
and here we say
sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener
which even i want to say
click
ok that is the first even second
reset board
reset
board
that we are basically passing that
okay
now
this is the initial case which we have
it
now beyond that i will add
this is the place what we have added
right now slides to add the players so
this is how we've initialized after that
let's
add
plates
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add
place
okay so take
event as a parameter
and say event
dot
prevent
prevent default this present default
will try to prevent
the default
uh you know
behavior which is submitting to we get
avoided and now here we say if
this
dot
player
one so we just define the property
called player1
if this dot player one dot what
value
okay
is blank
okay or
want to find it out its value also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i am saying
alert you
must
enter
the
name
for
each
field
the user has to add the values and after
that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this inside
this by saying cost
layer
form
container
again
const play from controller container
equal to
document dot
query selector
document query selector here we will
just pass
the value call
enter
icon
okay now we say cost
board main equal to
document
dot once again
query selector
code
underscore main
okay after that
clear
form container
dot
class
list dot class list dot
add here we're giving the name forward
height container
all right
add
container and after that you just say
board mail
board main
dot class list
dot
remove
height
hyphen
okay so we basically taken that
and after this what i will do i'll just
say player
x dot name
equal to
this dot
player 1
dot
value
ok this for player x copy this
player y
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which we
have implemented
well so
add player function is added right now
and uh after this add player we have to
basically call
one more that is called which returns
the current player so i'm saying return
current layer
and here what i will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
just variable
okay percentile
2 we're just adding it with this
okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you okay or else
so we're hearing like the current player
who says the current tail right now
well
after this adding the return current
player we're gonna add another function
that is known as call return the current
player return current player is having
this value and after that we need to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized
once again if the browser is getting
resized automatically the square size of
your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we're gonna say this option
equal window
dot add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here
and the second parameter what we are
passing is call on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is a function name for me
the one which we are passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
in this we are passing
board
underscore
cell
okay and then we're using another option
called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
off
set width
or
after that we are saying all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
cell
[Music]
and after that we are using cell
dot
style
height
equal to now he'll be using this
backtick and use this
dollar sign
and say
cell
height
and to you know pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's right over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
billboard
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document dot
once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also
okay so for those functions i can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add sell click listener
but i do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
our own
okay so we will just leave those
for a time being let's go back and
create another functions now so we just
want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt to make move
so
here we're trying to say
sell
click
event
for
player 2
attempt
to
make
move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function and give the name
of the function
to make move now
function
make
it takes
let's go back and try to check another
condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what
event dot
current target
sorry
even dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values
after that we use another variable
called let
cell 2
and
token
now here we are typing document
dot query selector
and here
you know using backtick
i'm using this file equal
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay
so this value we are taking it like that
after that we are using this situation
called if
sell
to
add token dot
inner html
exterminatory mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token dot inner html
equal to blank
then what next
so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay
so
in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current cell dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell
is
already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell see we have this property option
available called send to add token so we
using cell to add token
okay dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and we say
game mode
the one which you have created pass in
this game mode
this value call
current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
send
to add token dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for
is winner to check whether the user is
winner or not so we are saying
is
winner
okay and
after that we are saying
turn
plus plus
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being and we'll call
this little later on so
leave it as a for the time being
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not
okay so we are saying function
check
if
we're just checking the function
whether it is game is tie or not so here
we say
if
the condition is turn
greater than 7
alert
okay
well after that we are saying winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we will check
const
winning sequences
and here
sorry
here
we are having this array and having the
different conditions associated we say 0
2 probability we are checking it
and then i just copy it
well using 0 1 2 and here is saying
6 seven
eight
and zero three six again
zero
three
six
and once again one four seven
four
seven
and next we have a call two five eight
eight
then we are checking the vertical zero
for it
eight
and one more last option we will put is
called two four six
six so these conditions we are adding it
now
after this array we can say
varying sequences start
for each
we'll give the name called winning
compose
winning
combos
and inside this varying component we are
giving let
cell 1 equal to
varying combos position 0
then
that copy
and paste three times
cell two
cell three
and here we get the value called what
one
is two three values we're giving it and
after that
we're checking the condition
let's say
if
and here the conditions you're checking
what exactly that would be for the game
board we're saying
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
ampersand time percent
come down
game board
cell 2
i just want to copy the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
cell 3
after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
by cutting this condition called
consense
const
sense
and then equal to
document dot
get element by or sorry document or
query selector
all
and here let's select the position dot
board
and discard
cell
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside is what we are passing we are
saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
we're saying if
cell id
now we're talking about call cell id
triple equal to
cell
one or
saline
cell 2
or
salary equal to
cell 3
okay and in that case we can use
cell dot
just give the class name
winner
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
current layer equal to
document dot
get element by id
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current layer or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
player we can use
the current
player text
the new variable we are creating it
currently text document dot rather than
saying get element by id
we can say
query selector
and in this query selector will be given
the value pricing dot board
player
hyphen
the value which we are giving it here
and that
query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it in a
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just checked
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
current player whatever the value we are
using current text
dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you see
congratulations
along with
this dollar sign
and here we pass
player
dot
name
and here the tip tag is getting closed
like this
okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it
and after that
we give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written
we'll be talking about little later on
and just say return true okay
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition filler
if
winner
or you can say
check
if type
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board
header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us
and here they would like to check
whether the user is winner or not
so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case we have to say let
current player text
equal to
document
dot
query selector in this we'll be getting
the details like dot
board
and here we're gonna give the name
called player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put it in a capital letter
here
x
then we will say
current player
dot
inner html equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backtext because i want to
go multilines
that's the benefit of this backtick and
here we say in our inner html span
class
equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
style
process and here
we want to use
the statement
now this
value
we want to write it with name attribute
so it is getting close and here we are
saying dollar
with this player
x
dot
name
and then
close the
span tag and we say
you are
up
like this
and after that
we say div
class equal to
we're just gonna create a class which
later on we can apply the css style on
the top of that u hyphen r
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div type
so div tag is closed
that's it and now after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current layer
text
dot
inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we're going to write the span
class equal to here we say
main
hyphen hyphen same option we're going to
use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
the same rather than copying it again
and again
i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to
name hyphen iphone style player rather
than saying x you can use file
you are up you are
winner
okay so here it's getting closed
well
after this what we do to create another
function called reset port
function
reset board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using
the game board
at the same game board what we have used
it earlier
i'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember
that was a game code for me so i'll be
using the same keyboard
let me copy this
here
with the same condition
okay give me equal to this
after that line we will say let
sell to add token
sent to add token
equal to
document
dot query selector all
here
in this
i'll be using another class called
letter
now
cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square
and within this square we would like to
use square
dot
text content
equal to
black
after that
square
dot
parent element
classlist
dot
remove
and here you would like to say board
okay underscore in this call
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these changes classes were just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it n
winner equal to
false
after that winner equal to false we just
define another variable called define it
current player text
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all
so here
we're gonna use the name called board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
current player text dot
inner html equal to
once again we have to use the condition
for
up
and winner point so let me try to copy
this
we go inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
sales equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's check
the condition board
board
cell
and here once again we say sell stock
for each
dot
and here this is cell
add
event listener
which event i want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
handler
on
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click listener
remove cell click listener
now here we say
let
all cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell
and now we say
all cells
dot
for each
cell
and here we say send dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here
most of our javascript code is written
now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create
our html file now sorry the css
so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i'm going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.css in any other folder like in
static folder but i have just kept it
outside
now from this point onwards i would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called morning
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay
but i don't think so it's really needed
it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background color
because it's by default gonna be white
only
and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position i just say like
center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
here using cover
okay so it resize the background image
to cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes so first select
div
dot relative
inside this date alternative is first
say call position
position we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right purchasing 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height
dot
container or sorry hide hyphen container
here in hide hyphen container we will
display
colon
none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the cell we will say color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family i am selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that's called dot
will once again we can use another layer
but we can just use white or any color
you want or you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we're giving it's called zero
auto width
we're looking forward for eighty percent
next texture line
center
position
relative
now
next we're going forward for input field
in this input field we just say border
border 2 pixels
solid
and black
next
outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
four pixels eight pixels now margin
we are saying zero
zero 10 pixels
okay and finally
for pixels
after sparging we say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
focus
now here
border
two pixel
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want your submit button to be so
i'm saying
dot
submit hyphen btn
border
two pixels
solid
and black
adding
pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
18 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
five pixels
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take
white only
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate
with your submit button active and
submit button focus so we are saying dot
submit
hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outline
outline
none
next border
we're talking about called two pixels
solid
and the color
red
okay
so that's the one
and after that we like to use over dot
submit hyphen button
colon
over
what you want
change the background color
to what
white can use white smoke
well
here we like to use
a
dot
board here we'd like to use player
hyphen
so these are the classes we were using
in our javascript we remember
and here we say color
color we're using once again
right or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
texture line
center margin
10 pixels
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style
and here we are saying color
red and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about the
next important called border container
called board container dot
board container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay
next margin
we're taking is 0
and
auto
after that font size
font size we are taking 0
next border
bottom we are taking 2 pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
you remember this worksheet is one of
the very very season
three popular property here we're
defining 3 pixels
3 pixels
0 pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about call black
okay
so my
border color will be shading color will
be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we're defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining 100
okay divided by
this calculation
after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
center border
we are taking
two pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
this formula can use permanent
permanent marker
okay
now
next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board circle
board
cell iphone
winner
i would say rather iphone
[Music]
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
next
transform translate y
to minus 50
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay
now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're giving
winner
with dot
dot
winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container what
are the values we want to use it
that's you want to basically do it so
for this winner container what i would
rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
text align
center
margin
20 pixels
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset heading we will set
display none
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah now you could talk about
replay button dot
replay hyphen
vta
and here width
we make it
to
25 percent
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on outline
i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this lattice spacing would be again
zero
after that
text transform
this text track form value we are
talking about called
uppercase
next font size
font size
we are taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay
now in a similar line we can also have
call dot
replay iphone btn
colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
then color
we are making this call white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
we'll be using this
dot
okay
so this congratulations class will be
using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r
dot
winner
in this winner we'll be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking little pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two pixels
and then zero
okay that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
hyphen btn
this i'm saying with 50 percent
percent
so this is what my css file is all set
i know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch
so we have this index.html file with us
and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known is called
this
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this
using this external api
so here
where we have a call css with us
before that
we want
link
so within this link we want a one
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent
plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know
where exactly it is using
okay if i just copy and paste it
so i just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com
slash
oh spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url from where i can
take this kind of font so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it
so here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the
final outcome of my code
which is
index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class are attached so i need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes so that at
least i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a part tip h1
class equal to header
tic tac toe then we have a call div we
have a call
body
uh under this we have a call another div
tag so
just imagine how many type of classes
are available one we have called tip
class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a call
one more div tag so like that multiple
css files are there where we have to
apply the new css class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added
all those type of css classes which we
had that is called interplay
player form player container label
placeholder and player container and if
you see all different type of classes we
have attached this to
okay because
here only my css class will get applied
and the javascript will apply those kind
of dynamic css based on certain
conditions so these css classes are
already there added inside your html
page
our app.css is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic tac toe is a game it is expecting
and it says start game it says you must
enter a name for each field validation
is working
let me try to add
two names and say start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying a you are
up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the tic tac
door game is used so it is a classical
example of css
javascript and html together so this
time we're going to talk about our next
very interesting feature that is known
as called dealing with another example
that is called snake game so staying
keep is one of the very very powerful
example which i'm going to share with
you which will help you to understand
like how
we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project
okay that is something which is a snake
game let's see how the snake game is
important and how we're gonna deal with
this
these are our previous examples which we
have seen which i will call a project
which we have created that is called
quiz application and now we're going to
start working with our new project
now here first of all i'm going to
create a new folder
that is called snake again
and inside this is a game we need some
new
folders
uh first folder i'm going to create it
inside this that is called images
and
within this snake games i'm gonna create
few new files that is called
index
dot html
and uh here
i'm gonna create a new file name called
app
dot js
at the same time i'll be having some of
the css files if i need so i can say
app dot
css so total number of three files i
have it now
let me close down all the files
whichever i have opened it earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach
this is a snake game for us from where
we need to start
and we have an index.html file and here
i will create
our basic html syntax
and uh here i would like to include
our script tag
script
src equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing
our next
implementation of
snaking
now inside my body tag i would like to
have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on i'll be taking the
input from the client so we're saying
input
type equal to
so here we can justify the speed
and we can give id
equal to
game speed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value
and
min
equal to
1 that is the minimum value
and max equal to 9 that is the maximum
and minimum value we can offer beyond
that i won't allow the users to go
and step
that means the increment value that is
one
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button
and
value
equal to
start
and then agree equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after that
i can give some
bricks
so two bricks we're giving it and start
working with the div diagonal
and in this div tag i'll be using the
canvas
it is a html5 feature
we use canvas
and i just give id equal to
game
area
there is a canvas
and
after this canvas
we will
the tip tag is closed here after the dev
tag i can use another tab type
div
here i can say
class equal to
i may not have any class written but i
can say
class equal to related so later on if i
want to apply any css style
i can certainly apply
and after that i can offer the images
okay so i may not have any images right
now so i just leave this image blank
right now
okay and this is script src i'll load it
only
before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on the bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so i can see
values
now it will go maximum nine that is how
we have given and minimum is one
start is the button which is not doing
anything but later on we can allow some
logic inside this
now
we have to start working with our main
javascript tag this is my amp.js and
here onwards we will use
some of the properties okay which i want
to initialize it so using var
game
start
equal to none
initialized
second game speed
equal to
next game area
null
game area context
area
width
equal to
zero that is in integer value
give area height
game area
equal to zero
again then solve it
so with equal to 0
play score
equal to 0 again next snake
equal to null
next snake food
next snake direction
equal to
null
snake speed or else i can say speed size
speed size
equal to
zero
next we have our timer
equal to
so these number of properties
we've initialized
okay
now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here in initialized
we would like to use some of the
properties
first we are saying
game start equal to document dot
get element by id
here i can give the value call
hash
game start
let me put it in double quotes
okay
start
now game speed now these all basically
the values are there game start game
speed
these all values we have to take it
okay so we will be seeing these values
one by one
so let me say that another one that is
called game speed
game speed equal to again
document dot
get element by id now we are passing
the game speed
game
speed
now
here
once again i will take another point
game area
i say game
here you have to give the value called
game area
okay these values we have taken
now we will be talking about called game
area context
game area context equal to
game area
dot get context
okay
and in this game context will be using
what type of context using 2d
okay because i want to have
the kind of 2d so this is how the kind
of environment we want to set
next we talk about game area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
game area height
equal to 600
now solve it
we are initializing with 20
next game area dot width
okay so game area
dot
width equal to
game area width
and then we define game area dot height
dot
equal to
game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this
okay
now after that we have to start writing
the logic here i'm saying game start
game start
dot now we have to line uh which event
you would like to take so i will say on
click
on
so when i basically click what should
happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here i'm
saying this dot
this dot disabled
equal to
true
so i'm going to disable these values
and after that we want to call another
function inside this
but which function let's do that so here
we are saying function
start game
start
game
and
here in start game
we want to define the initial score see
the initial score for the player will be
certainly zero so we say
player
score
equal to zero
after that
direction in which direction you want
the snake to move so we are saying snake
direction equal to
right
in the right direction
then speed size
the value of sorry the variable which
you've defined so speed size equal to
because
it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it certainly will be string type
so we have to use percent
so we're using this option called power
sent and here we are using
game speed
dot
[Music]
value
okay so we are using this value gain
speed dot value now here we would like
to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay
what if condition
[Music]
see this function we are writing called
start game
because there are certain things which
you need to
make it
so like that we have to define it so
function initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
on click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started
start game and now we'll be writing the
logic for this so here we are saying if
we're using speed size
missing if
a speed size
greater than
9. in case if it is
the values hard coded it
then we would like to write a logic here
and what this logic would be it says if
it is greater than 9 we say speed size
equal to
nine
we basically initialize to what nine
here we say elsa
speed size
is
zero
we say speed size
sorry
a speed size
equal to one
that means if it is less than zero i
will be making it minimum to one if it
is greater than nine i'll be making it
to nine maximum
and that's it
okay
so after this elsif condition
is getting closed we are seeing speed
size equal to
one
so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards
by saying
x
position
and
then the y
and here the y value will be what
cell wait that means how far it can go
so it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call cell width
which we have given here
after that what we have to do is
we have to define our own function
called
clear interval
and this clear interval perform any
logic whichever i would like to make it
okay so here after that snake dot push
value has been given
here i will be creating one more
function here that's known as call
create food okay so here we're saying
create
food so great food will be the function
for me now you might be thinking where
this function is but this function will
be declared soon within your application
but here first we are saying the
function called clear interval
clear interval with the timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that
this clearing treble will be saying
timer
equal
to set interval
with this we are saying create game area
create
now
here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement
so
here we are giving this call create food
is a function we are calling after that
we are calling this clear interval
interval will be just like in a typical
function which is there after that we
are using this option called create game
area
so
[Music]
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you
how you can call this function create
food and how to create it first well so
we are talking about a functionality
called create game interval so this
create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the saying set
interval
this function is not it there so we have
to basically go back and create this
function within my application
fine so
what we will do is just particular one
we will try to comment it for a time
being
okay so here we have a call what create
interval
in this create interval will be
passing any parameters which we are
passionate about as a timer here and
here we are calling this call create
food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
and this function create food let's go
and write a logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food we say snake food
snake food equal to
and here in our curly braces we use two
direction x and y
we say in x we say
math dot
around
and inside this we say
math
dot
random
after this math.random function we have
to just take this calculation
and check the another parameter called
game area width
game
area width
minus
cell width the one which you are passing
it and here after that we'll be
performing the calculation by saying
celebrate
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similarly we would like to use for my y
coordinate also
now
math dot round round dot number game
area
game area height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
minus
seventh let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay so that's where exactly it got
closed
okay
now
here our applications is now ready by
calling the function called create4
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so we are saying
function create game area
create
game
area there's another function for me
after this create game area there will
be another function i'm going to create
it
that is called control
function
control
okay after that we are going to write
one more function called function
right score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call right score
there's another function which you're
going to write it out here that is
called function
right score is done now we say create
square
create
this is another function
and finally we'll have a call change
direction
function
change
direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it
here in our system
well
we know very well that we have taken
this call create food grade food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
great game area we are defining two
locations var
x direction and y interaction so we say
uh a snake
x
equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we are saying dot x
for the x direction
we are saying var
snake
y
equal to
snake
position we are taking once again zero
and
dot okay so two directions we have taken
x direction and y direction
now here we are starting
gain
area
context
dot fill style at the united variable it
is a property
fill style equal to which color you want
to fill this up
so i'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this game
area context again
dot fill react
fill react
now keep the position values i'm saying
0 comma 0 comma
game
area game area width
comma
game area height
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stroke style let me take this game area
context again
dot
stock style
stroke style
equal to now we give the another color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same gave me the context dot stroke
react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
comma
game area width
game
area
height
so we are passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic
of the directions
now see the when you talk about snake
game it moved left right and center
up and down so now in this case we have
to increment the situations accordingly
so we say if
the snake direction
if the snake direction
equal to
right
then we say snake
x
plus plus
now
else if
also
same
let's copy this
snake direction
left
what should happen
here we say
snake
x
minus minus
okay so we're taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're taking about left right we
set down
so in this case we say snake
y
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
let me say
snake
y
minus minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this else if condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition
we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that you say
if snake x
f snakes x
-1
or
snake x
double equal to
game
area width which we have taken
divided by
cell weight
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus one
okay so we're giving this call minus one
or
snake y
stick by equal to
gain area height
to save it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah i will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created some time back and inside this
control
it will take some parameters so what
those parameters we can pass
we can say
snake
x
comma
snake y
third parameter will be
snake
so this could be my another function
okay
so here
we are passing the conditions just like
that
okay now here
this is
available to use a parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for write
score
which is so far the function is only
created not described more so we are
writing the right score score will be
written here
and here we are saying clear interval
because the timer will be stopped
okay i'm using game start
dot
disabled
equal to
false
and after that
return
that's it
so this is the logic for we have written
to this particular example
now we can use
another if more conditions here just to
check the behavior of my code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
well here we have finished this game
start dot disabled equal to false
and we returned
now going forward after this letter
we would like to have another condition
for the snake x so we say if
snake x
if a snake x double equal to
snake food
dot x
okay snake foot cortex
ampersand
snake
y
double equal to
snake
food dot
y then in this case i will say
var new head
bar
new xory
var
new head equal to here
x
colon
snake x
y
colon snake boy
snake x and y colon
snake
y
these options we are taking it
now
after that we are using this option
called player score
plus
equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
create food method again and here after
that we're using the else condition
and in this else condition
we are saying var
new head
equal to
snake
dot pop
okay and we are saying new head
dot x
equal to snake x
and new head
dot y equal to
snake y
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
dot on shift
and shift
snake dot and shift and here we are
passing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for loop by saying
for
var equal to
r i
i equal to 0
then
i is less than
snake
dot
length
and
snake dot length
and once i
plus plus
okay later on we just use the option
called
create
square
and in discrete square we are passing
snake
snake position
i
dot
x
comma
same
snake
dot y
that's it
so it's getting closed here and after
that we are calling the same option
with this snake food let me copy this
again
and here rather than
using this we can say snake food dot x
and snake foot dot y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now it will start working
with your control
control needs to take three parameters
x y and the array so we are passing this
option called
control and in this control we are
taking x
comma y
comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
var
i equal to zero
i
is less than
array dot
length
and i
plus plus
and after that we'll be using this
option called if condition and here we
say
array
i
which value you're passing dot x
double equal to
x
ampersand time percent
here we say array
with a position called i
and in this we are saying dot y
and this position we are checking for
the y condition
for the y condition so it returns what
true
written
through
the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return
now that's it now we are talking about
this option name called write score
this right score we have to use the game
area context
game
area context dot
font
equal to
here we'll be passing this situation
we're saying 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
sends
iphone
service
after that we're using call game media
context again let me copy this
take it again call game area context dot
fill style equal to here i'll be using
another color now
we say hash
okay
now after that we are saying once again
the kmd context dot
fill
text
here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say
plus
player score whatever it is
with game area with
game area width
slash
minus
and then
again game area with
slash
so this is where exactly the right score
where the data will be actually written
okay next we'll be having this option
called create square and this great
square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about call x
second is taking y
and now here we're using this game area
context
same
dot
fill style
equal to let me give the color
after this we're using call same gary
and text
game area text dot
fill react
here we are saying x
multiply by
cell with comma y
this is what
my great square is now we are left with
only one option that is known for change
direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters
now here we are passing this option
called workkeys
equal to e
dot
and
later on we want to say if
keys
equal to
okay
am percent ampersand
is snake direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake direction
equal to
down so we are changing the directions
here
okay now let me try to copy this
and here we use elseif
[Music]
four times
okay
so here we talk this
30 40 and here we say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 27
39 38 27
and here we say up
let's change to what
left
down
right
here we say
up
left
the three options we have changed and
last but not least here
i will just use
window dot
on key down
equal to
change directions
and
window
dot
on
load
okay equal to
initialize that's how exactly we want to
use now and this function what we have
defined in initialize
okay
so in this initialize
we are having this game start dot on
clicking and all so you have a call
start game now this start game will be
calling it here
okay so in start
we were called snake we have called
snake dot push
and after that we are calling
this function call what
create food
clear interval and here we say
timer equal to
here set clear interval and here
change
game area
slash
size
let's say you want to use it
okay everyone so our code is almost
ready so we have this complete
javascript ready with me
now it's time to basically use within my
html
just to check how it may behave
so in my html page i have written this
normal speed
number
game speed value
button start we will call game start
after that we have a call canvas where
we written id equal to call game area
dev classic to relative
and
that's it and here we have a call script
sr is equal to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if i try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay i really do not see any changes in
my code
okay
despite i'm having this because
the css content is actually missing
okay because then only my code really
look
better
because if there is no css
it wouldn't really make
good towards my application
okay and i also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
later on let me go back and try to bring
css into this picture now
so first of all
have this
index.html file with me
and here i want to use css so inside my
head tag we want to use
link
real
equal to
style sheet
okay hr
equal to
app
dot
css
okay
now
here
in my css we want to offer certain
details
what those details i want to start
working with i will start with my body
part
body
so we want to offer the font family
so
font family maybe a little bit later on
i can use it first i want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
auto
later text
align
center
next font size
font size 150 pixels
also 150
and here we want to say background
background image
since i do not have any image so i will
just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise you have to say
url
and insert this url
it gives some values but i leave it as a
blank because i do not have any image i
will say background color
in this background color i can just use
white
after that height
i can just say 800 pixels
after that
background position
background position i want to use center
then background repeat
background repeat i want no repeat
then background size
okay let's see if there's an effect in
my
okay i see it's now
in the middle
better
now
inputs canvas we have to basically take
that here we just talk about call input
okay in this input i say font size
font size may be optional i can
make it
but let me just say font size 100
percent
then text align
center
then padding
i want to say five pixels
and
seven pixels
okay looks better now
well here after that i can use canvas
in this canvas
i want to see the background color
i just say
white after that border radius
for the radius i can say 20 pixels
then
shadow if i want to use it
so i just say box shadow
box shadow i can say three pixels
five pixels
and six pixels
and the color is
black
let's check
awesome
so i can see here
[Music]
the
logic is there so shadow you can easily
see how it has been using
and
that's it and this div
i can say
div
dot
relative
position
absolute
top
here i'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly
i program now when i say start
okay so there may be some error here
let's see cannot set a property of call
on click
null
so this we can just check this into this
uh
gamestop.on click
let's check
anyways
we just try to fix that issue in
while
but anyways we have our created css and
now going forward we'll be implementing
the rest of the logic within my code
okay everyone so we have changed some
names here because there was some value
was mismatched so we have basically
changed those values
with your properties and now when i try
to relaunch my application
by
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html file when i try
to add
so
it's just as usual same let me say start
and here you can see game start when i
go up you see like it's starting right
now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play it earlier
okay we can just change the direction go
up and you can see the score 10 is being
placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value call
what zero
by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
right
so like that you can see and
automatically this will be position this
is what's called food that is how we
have used in my example on call app.js
you can see we are using this example
name called food
create food so in create food of the
specific interval time this would be
automatically created and the snake will
eat and increase the size of the code
okay that's it and now the css has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first game which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example this video on react.js helps you
build two fun applications using the
library as you all know react is a
widely used javascript library to build
user interfaces for applications
this video will make you realize why it
is adopted so widely
so first we'll build a calculator app
and then we'll move on to building a
spotify clone
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
now i'm sure you're excited to build
these apps so let's begin
this time we're gonna introduce you
another very interesting project using
this javascript html css
so called calculator application so
let's get started let me try to delete
first those files which we really do not
need it now
uh
we delete this all
yeah now i'll be creating a new folder
now and give the name called
calculator
and in this calculator app once again we
need some new files which is called
index
dot html
and we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is called app.js
so these three files
required now first of all i would start
with
index.html file where we will be
creating a template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a good body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator app so that will be my h1
heading
after that we'll start working with the
div tag
now within this div
i would have to create lot many classes
i may not have lot many cs classes but
we can give some classes here so we can
say class equal to
container
okay
so within this div tag we're going to
create a table now because i want to
organize it
so i'm starting with the table within
this table
tr tag
and within this track i need a td
now in this td i need few things call
call
span
equal to 3
another value
and here
i want to offer the text box
input type equal to
text
okay input text
id equal to give the name called result
that will be the final outcome while
pressing all the different buttons id
equal to result and
class
equal to
screen remember i haven't created those
css classes but but we're giving some
names but later on we can utilize it
while creating those css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now inside this td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here it is input text sorry i would like
to better say button because i will be
having
buttons
okay
input time equal to
button
value
equal to
c
and uh on click
equal to i may not have any function
right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some dummy
name here i'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function will
get called
and after that class
equal to
clear
yeah so this is my button tag
after this the td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row which is getting
close we're going to start working with
another table row
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here and inside this td i'll
be having another button we get created
so i'll just say
this is another button now input equal
to button value
one
or click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call one
okay and class equal to member
class equal to
number
and here after that td tag is getting
closed
okay now we have to start another td tag
here
okay like that you have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 on click product
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what
number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like
now i can see the buttons like in c one
two three but yes i'm gonna create few
more buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here
and create a few more buttons so this is
where the table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this
and paste it again
how to create
the button
like in
three four something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
yeah
i'll give the value called three
so val equal to two well equal to three
display three
and then afterwards
just giving the value call
forward slash
and here also we're gonna keep the value
and here class equal to operator
operator after that you have to do the
value count four
and then followed by five six seven
so here we give four
four
five
six
after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about call seven
then we have to have eight
okay nine
okay after that we're giving call plus
and display
plus class equal to operator
operator okay so here
you can see the table data is getting
closed and here the table is also
getting closed and after the stable row
you can start working with
another table over here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
again
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is valid equal to
dot and here we give the value called
decimal
okay now display zero
so after giving this dot to basically
take what the value
zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have the other one
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that
we'll be once again
taking this and this time rather than
giving this zero
we'll be using this call as a button and
value equal to
equal
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this soft will not be
passing anything
it will write a normal function
and plus equal to
equal
okay
so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we'll be using
value equal to
multiplication
display
plastic
and here we'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table is
getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your dev tag is also getting
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome so we have got uh
all those
necessary calculator behavior
which
we wanted to
reveal
okay now our next statement will be once
we're giving this c then we have a
column one two three
and then forward slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so
let me check whether we have used six or
not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before
minus
six
equal to
number
okay so we are almost set now
so we are having this uh
look and feel
in this we are giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then
plus related behavior so we are all set
now and after that we'll be basically
applying the css as well as the
javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
uh this outlook is looking properly or
not see what my expectation is after one
two three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next and then
seven eight nine and again forward still
but i can think this is absolutely
unorganized
so after this when we say
this uh forward slash which we have used
after hyphen
okay your td is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start
another tr here
okay
so that i can put them into the another
level now so under this tr i can use
this td now so after this minus
after four five six
minus
once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
okay
starting another tier after that we talk
about 789
okay plus
see here talking about 789 plus here the
table is getting close and it is
starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which i
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it later on
okay because you can see eight is
missing right now
so here
seven
we copy this
equal to eight
eight
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized
so the moment i expect my application so
we have a call dot here then zero then
equal to and then multiplication
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel so i need to
go ahead and use what css because
without css i really can't utilize this
in a proper way so i have to start
working with a css friend now
in css front how to start first we will
go back to my code and here in my css we
will start working with
font family but before font family i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using called t
that looks nice
okay so
i will be using this app.css
in my html to see the look how it has
been appeared right now
so in my index.html file
on the top under my head section
link
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css
we want to use
some h1 correct tool so here
we would like to use the h1
texture line
center
color
white
margin top
margin top would like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement
will be called screen so we say
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
diagram color gray
sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
we're using this
then we talk about cursor
we would like to save 10 pixels
and then
merging
save auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want this for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me and rest of the details
will be showing you one by one and now
we'll be talking about
okay
input
type equal to button
for input type equal to
button
okay
input application button of type
over the model
overall button i say
background color
change to what
right what else i can say
let's walk
okay
and
when the button is active
what i want
let me copy
and put a little button and here i say
active
and this color should be orange red
like this
you can see now how it is basically
looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about operators
operator should behave different so i'm
saying dot
operator
in this operator we are saying
background color
background color orange
okay and padding
i want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using call border
sorry
that border
i'm using this called solid
and then black
and
after this bit
i'm using 100
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursor
it has to be pointed
okay that's it let's check
perfect so they should turn back to what
to your
orange color
and uh
you can see the moment you take
microsoft returns to white
perfect and now those were type number i
also want to change them
so for number
for number i want to say the same option
padding i want 5 pixels
then i need height
of type 40 pixels
then i say color
black into accents for it
black
two pixels
then width
i would say point width
few
other type of options
okay that i'm talking about called
decimal or decimal i need to have a
different options with me
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it and i say for
does it
so for decimal background color will be
light blue
padding 5 pixels color black
border solid
okay black two pixels with hundred
percent height forty pixels five cursor
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light blue
now
i talk about
clear
okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color background color is
i'm changed to light salmon
light salmon
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width 100
height 40 pixels
fine
so cursor
pointer
file margin
auto and margin bottom
let's check
perfect not looks beautiful
okay
now
here
after giving these details we're talking
about call equal part dot equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so we recall
background color id color
just change to
light green
and
after this
since it is equal so we say padding five
pixels is okay color black fine border
fine with hundred percent high 40 pixels
color and cursor pointers just i don't
need to
it's for dot equal and i want
for container
container
in this container width i want forty
percent
red forty percent background color white
okay
now here
padding is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all you call width
display
block
which we're taking margin
okay in merchandising to pixels
auto
okay now align cells
go to
center
okay border radius
border it is let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
block shadow 5 pixels
black
and padding
so these are details i have it
okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell
display block border radius padding
and then
writing 15 pixels we have given audi
i don't need to give it again
margin
okay fine
box shadow let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay so this is where exactly my
application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 we're taking background color
let's bring it below then align cell
display block
okay margin
okay
and uh border radius
and uh
fine so i think we're all good now
so that's it so we'll try and implement
the javascript part well everyone so our
css file is ready
our html is ready it's time to just uh
go ahead and talk about my
final portion that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just say function
display
function display which takes
val as in parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result
okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay there is a function
after that we have another functions
available here called function solve
here in the song
we just use the value called let x equal
to
document dot
get element by id
result
okay
dot
value sorry
value
okay and say connect
y
equal to
perform the calculations for they will
be using one function called
eval
and type
access and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document dot
created my id
result
dot
value equal to
y
okay
now
later on
i'll try to use another function here
function
clear
screen
result
three functions are associated with me
and these three functions
are the part of this javascript file
which i'll be calling it
at the end before
the water tag get closed so here
script
i will say plus
equal to 8 absolutely i say c is clear
the screen
divided by
equal to 3 awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is the css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in of this template
beautification and here last year for gs
which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay if getting your learning started is
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
let's start with uh creating a simple
demo on react.js and we are going to
create a simple application uh that will
connect to an online music streaming
service called spotify and we will call
our application music app so let's get
started the first step is to first get
the node.js platform and server
installed to do that let me go to google
and let's just type node.js
and here is the website
nodejs.org there are two versions
available the lts which is the stable
version and the current we'll prefer the
stable so we'll click on that and you
can see we have an option which is
called save file the moment this file is
saved to the disk we just need to double
click on it and keep clicking on the
next button to get it installed on our
system and we also have a documentation
available here so which explains most of
the features of the node platform and
there are binaries available for
different os's mac windows etc so you
can select the right witness 32-bit
64-bit and the right os
and then go ahead and download the
specific
version that suits your platform and you
can see here that there are different
there are also help files available that
will allow you to go through the
installation documents for node.js
installation on linux etc so to start
with uh i'm opening up the command
prompt and here is where we're going to
call the node package manager using the
node package manager which is
pre-installed with your standard node.js
installation we will initialize our
react application so we would say react
dash app and
we want to now go and create an
application called music app in this
folder so as a prerequisite for the demo
all we need to do is install node.js
from nodejs.org the official website
just download it and install it and
that's when you open the command prompt
you fire npm which stands for node
package manager in it for initialize
react dash app is a standard keyword to
in uh initialize and create a skeletal
structure of a react.js application and
the name of the app is music app so
we'll hit enter we'll give this some
time and you can see it's
started downloading the core
react.js libraries and it is attempting
to create
our application so it's installing all
the prerequisite packages and scripts
that are required initialize and create
a new react.js application called music
app now once this application is created
all we would require is an online editor
so you could use an offline or an
on-premise editor as well so any editor
of your choice it could be atom or
sublime text or webstorm and for this
demo we are going to use visual studio
code which is
a free editor available by microsoft and
you can just google for visual studio
code again this is not visual studio
professional edition etc that we use for
building our c-sharp or mbc-based
applications this is a lightweight
editor for building javascript based
footstep full applications so so while
this installs let's go and take a look
at
visual studio code so this is the visual
studio code editor and this is the
editor that we've
installed directly downloaded from
visualstudiocode.com
and installed it and all we need to do
is open up this folder that would be
created with all the prerequisite files
in it we just save file open folder and
we would open that folder within our
visual studio code editor so we'll give
it a while
until that application gets generated
and once it's created we will again
implement the component based design and
architecture and the data flow between
the components and we also look at
connecting to a live data source which
is a json set of characters that we
would consume which is a restful service
the set of music tracks exposed as a
restful api endpoint by spotify which is
a premium streaming service we will
connect to that and we will look at
accessing some of the music tracks on
that website okay so we've got uh the
application created here so let's
minimize this and
we'll open up our editor all we've got
to say is file and open folder and
let me go to the react.js demo folder so
this is the music app that got created
and that's exactly what we're going to
open up here so we'll navigate to
that folder it's called music app we'll
select it
and have it opened in our application so
you can see here we've got a note
modules folder this has all of the
pre-installed packages that make up the
react.js library we've got a folder
called public which will have the
index.html file that's the root file
that will launch so this is the single
page application that we typically
create
in react you have a single page which on
which we're going to load multiple
components so that's the index.html and
then we could go and create
a folder structure uh currently if i
open the source folder we can see a
single app.js file and that basically is
the file that has
the source code in javascript for a
single component which
we are interested in adding on to our
page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding css file and
then we've got
the a public folder with the index.html
file which is going to be
the root html file that launches
when we run our application
so let's uh go right up here and let's
add
a link to an additional file so i'm
going to link to another style sheet
okay so we say relationship is equal to
stylesheet and the type is going to be
text
and css
and
we will reference a file called
reset
dot css and this is a file that we look
at uh adding up later on it doesn't
exist at this point in time so we will
connect this and that's purely for
styling purposes uh so that we can have
all of our css styles defined there next
thing i'll right click on the public
folder we'll create a new file we'll
name this file as reset
dot css so that's going to be the css
file that will have all of the css
styling that we're going to apply and
i'm going to use a ready code snippet
for the css code so let me just uh okay
so i'll all i'll do is uh i'll just go
and pick up
a ready css file that i can just go and
use
if you look here i have a set of
css files that are created that we're
just going to use
within our application and
and that will avoid us spending a lot of
time on the styling so that we can focus
on our core concepts
which is actually learning how component
based architecture works and how do we
set up components and have data
communication between them in react so
here is a file called
reset.css let me just fire up
notepad and i'll just open up this file
copy up the text here and i'm going to
just paste it within
my reset.css and if you look at the code
very simple it's all about
styling so we've got
article aside etc all html5 tags set up
as display block so they take up the
entire width of the page we've got some
padding margin and font size etc defined
we've removed list styling for the
unordered and ordered lists specifying
the line height for the body tag so
basically uh just styling up tables and
uh so nothing nothing to do with react
here it's just about simple uh css that
we've added up uh and now we need to
actually go in and dive into create
creation of the components that we need
so let's right click uh on the source
folder so i'll select the source folder
we'll right click there and that's where
we're going to create a new folder which
is called components okay so this is the
components folder now that's going to
hold
all of the components within it within
the components folder let me create uh
another new folder and i'm going to call
it app and this is exactly how we are
expected to structure all of the code
that we have now i already have a css
and app.js which are the root components
that were added by default and all i'm
going to do is i'm going to move them
within this folder called app okay so
there's a proper segregation of
responsibility and
all of the code that
deals with a particular component is all
added into respective folders and this
really improves the maintainability of
the application
going forward now we need some images
and i'm just going to make use of some
set of images that i've downloaded from
the web and
here are the set of images that i have
so i'm just going to copy all of them
and we'll come to our music app and
we'll go into the components and app
folder and that's where we're going to
add all of the files and you've seen all
of those image files getting added so
these are just icons and images we're
going to use for our music tracks inside
our application now uh let's move to the
app.css file and
this is where we've actually got
so the app.css file is the file that's
going to style up
the
all of the style rules that we've added
into the root app component and
this is what we'll have to revamp so
i'll just get rid of this code and
we'll probably add something for the
body tag the html tag and the root
element let me say hash root and let's
set the height to 100
coming to all of the html across the
page we'll give it a font size of 10
pixels
and
the h1 elements
let me give it a padding of
0.77
and 0 let's set
a background color give it a background
color and just select
some random color here that can be
applied then we'll set up the text
alignment which is going to be the
center of the page we'll set up the font
family the font family is
and this is part of
sans serif what else do we add let's add
up the font size one 1.88
and also the color so again uh these are
standard uh html and css elements so
nothing really that
has to be done that is specific to
react here so again we are bringing in
the highlight class so there is a class
called highlight that we will create
later in the
html view of this component and we will
set this to a red rgb component so
combination of 46 113 and 238 okay so
that's uh pretty much done let's move on
and also add up for the anchor tag let's
add up some text decoration and set it
to none so that the anchor tags don't
come up with those underlines and of
course we'll provide a color of hash
okay so a white color there now coming
to the h2 element for the h2 element
let's have font family and again i'm
going to use uh so i'm going to use
the font family that we defined here
bracket and we change this to probably
1.55 okay now coming to the app tag uh
let me just save this and create a copy
of it uh there was some content that
i did delete and
i can simply go and make use of it so
i've just undone all of the deletion so
this is uh something that i can't uh if
i can use something i can just probably
use it from the tag below so let me
start with a height here and let's say
the height of the header is hundred
percent of the app sorry not header
padding 0 17
the background and i'm going to change
that to background url so the background
url or let's say the background image
will have a url property okay and that
url is going to be dot slash
pg1 dot jpeg so that's the image that
we've added some in the previous step
let's also add
background size so we'll add background
size and set it to cover i also need a
background position set it to center
let's have background repeat which is
set to
no repeat so that we don't have the
image
in a grid format
and then i would need this bit of it
let's take up the font family we'll
maintain the same font family let's use
font weight the font weight is going to
be 500 and the color is going to be hash
so that's a white color then we come to
dot
app.playlist so that's going to be
another class that we are going to use
dot but app dash playlist is what we
we're going to name it and let me say
that the display should be flex
flexible display and we will justify the
content to leave spaces
in between all right so that finishes
that bit and now uh
let's write up a media query for the
responsiveness of this page so this is
media for only screen and
max width is going to be one zero two
zero pixels okay and the class name that
we'll provide later is obviously app
playlist so for this screen size we
would align all the items
to the center and we change the flex
direction okay so we seem to be good
with
the css for the app as of now and that's
the app.css
that we created let me save everything
okay let's check
for any kind of
additional so all three of errors no
errors now things are good in the app
css and it's time to move to the next
step of building this application uh now
we'll have to go and add up
the code for uh the app.js file so let's
dive into the app.js file and this is
where
we will actually need to go and add
all of the code that is required for the
app component so all the code that's
relevant to
the app component we are going to add up
inside this specific component itself
which is going to be obviously the
app.js file so we have skeletal code
which is import importing the react
library and uh let me get rid of the
basic sample logo we'll have app.css
that's getting imported here
besides that a lot of other files that
we'll have to get in so uh let me import
playlist and this is these are the
components that we'll create uh as we go
forward and
we're going to get this from the
playlist folder
and the component the file is going to
be called playlist so we'll add that
then we'll have to go and also import
search bar so what we're basically doing
is we're going to split this app into
different components there's going to be
one component that manages the playlist
of all the tracks uh one component will
act as the search bar so that's the
search bar component that we're going to
add so searching for tracks will be
managed by this we'll have another
component that we'll create that will
get imported into the root app component
which is a search results so this is
going to display the record set with the
set of results as an outcome of the
search criteria so search results slash
search results and finally we'll go and
import spotify that's the spotify
service from so we'll create a utility
folder which will hold
the code that connects us to spotify so
that's what we are adding up next so all
of the imports are done one component
that manages the search bar so that's
search bar search results let me correct
the spellings there that search results
that spotify and playlist so that's done
now let's move on to the class that
we're going to create here so let's
create a class app that goes and extends
react dot component so that's going to
be a react.js component so that's a
constructor we discussed about props or
properties and state management and
that's what we are implementing we are
using the super keyword as a best
practice so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor and also
we pass the values up the chain to the
superclass which is the root component
class now we're going to initialize
a variable called state that's going to
manage the state and we are interested
in tracking our search results so we'll
have multiple results so we'll store
that as an array the playlist would have
different names so we'll just call ours
new playlist that's the default name and
we will also store a list of tracks
which is going to be playlist tracks so
playlist tracks is going to be a list of
tracks and let's close
this block okay and this two is going to
be initialized within the constructor so
we'll add it here and now we need to do
the binding we discussed uh data binding
so let's look at
creating a search variable which will
hold this dot search dot bind and bind
to the context of this very class so we
are passing this pointer then we'll
create
another variable called add track which
to this dot add track dot bind and all
this functionality is what we're going
to add going forward so right now we're
just setting up the bindings then we'll
have capability to remove a track so
we'll say remove track so remove track
equal to this dot remove track dot pint
and let's fix that so and all of these
two is going to be initialize as part of
the constructor so that's where we're
going to add it then we need to update
update the playlist name so we need
functionality that will help us to
update the name of the playlist so
functionally that helps us to update the
playlist name so this dot update
playlist
name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind and this
is the pointer that we'll pass i need to
save the playlist so this dot
save playlist
equal to this dot save playlist dot find
and pass this and then i would also need
to remove the track that has been
searched for from the playlist so remove
track search go to this dot
okay remove track search and
dot find
and finally one last function that
executes
all of these which probably will bind to
bind to this context so all the
declarations are done in the constructor
now we need to provide the definitions
for all the methods that we actually
have added here so let me select this
tab inside and let's start with the
search function so we'll define the
search first it takes
some variable value that it searches on
and then i'm going to say spotify dot
search i'm going to search for term dot
then and that's an observable so the
moment it the search returns a value it
it's going to call this uh callback
function and that's when we want to set
the state and we're going to set the
state for search results to whatever is
passed by the system so the search
results are going to be returned as a
callback and that's what we store as an
updated state now coming to the add
track method so let's scroll up and
we'll say add track and this will take
the track to be added let's declare a
temporary variable called tracks equal
to this dot the current state of all the
tracks that are there in the playlist
now if track start find i'm going to
call the find method so if we are able
to find which means that the track is
already there in the playlist then we
would not want to add it if it's not
there in the playlist that's when we
would want to go and add it the triple
equal to is an equality operator that
will check for both a batch value match
and a match on the data type as well
okay so if the track is uh already saved
to nothing if the track is not safe just
track the track id because that is the
track that will uh have to be added if
it's not if it's already there then just
return if it's not there then we've got
to go to this variable called tracks
we'll use the javascript method called
push and we will push the current track
into this tracks array and then update
the state so we want to set the state of
the playlist tracks and this is how
your state management that we discussed
in detail is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now
let's talk about the remove track so
that's the remove track function and
that's the track that we want to remove
so let's let tracks equal to this dot
state dot playlist tracks those the set
of current tracks that we have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is a javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is not equal to the
track dot id which means this particular
track is not there in the list
okay so you need to remove that and
again i have a method called as unshift
which will actually get rid of the track
in the array and then we've got to so
we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here
we're going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of search results and
then we are going to say tracks equal to
tracks dot filter current track current
track dot id not be equal to the track
dot id and then this is where we would
want to say this dot set
state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making that change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track uh
is now the remove track and the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it removes
the track from the search criteria so
the search component which is managing
searching of the tracks that will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update playlist name which will take
the name of the track to update and this
dot set state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so
here
let me create a constant variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change we'll take
all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot uri so
we actually want to go and uh now save
this on a spotify so that's the reason
we'll access
spotify's save playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom
name that i want to provide and the
playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps from a
maintainability perspective so even
though everything is in the same file
it's well classified and differentiated
into different code blocks so we'll add
the anchor tag and we'll say href is
http localhost so that's the default
server port on which this application
will run okay and we want to give it a
custom url name of musical file so the
h1 terminates will then say div class
name equal to app within that this is
how we're going to inject our search bar
that's going to be the search bar
component injected here and on search so
that's the custom event we will call a
method called search so on search we
just call we bind to a method called
this dot search then we'll open up
another div here we'll have class name
equal to app dash
playlist and if you remember that's
exactly the css
class name that we referred to in the
css file we have another component
called search results
that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button the search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the duties function and it will remove
it from the search results text box then
we have another component called
playlist and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current uh component
itself so whatever you put into the app
component or into the respective
component those values will be then
passed out here to these individual
functions okay so that's with the
playlist couple of things we'll have to
do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have remove functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
uh on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etcetera that
you provide in other programming
languages so that's done we've created
our app component now let's create
another folder under components and
we've got to define all our various
components here this folder is going to
be for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add two files within it
the search bar dot css okay and another
file that we'll need here is search bar
dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be 6.94
rem and
margin bottom is going to be 6.33
rem all right now let's add up for the
search bar so that's search bar we'll
add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.88
the border should be one pixel solid
white the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge uh to
give a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll
set up the border radius then we've got
margin bottom so we've got a bottom
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color c3f
so that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and zero the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash one db 9 5 4. that
gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got
a font
family let's set up the font family to
the same standard font 8t
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size
to 0.83
rem correct this
and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic
css properties so that will add a slight
transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up uh
let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove in fact let's remove the
border we we would not want a border on
the button that would look odd so i'll
get rid of the border and color we'll
specify as per our standard color that
we've been using okay so that's the
color we've specified and then i've got
font weight of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case uh if we hover around
the button we would want
the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and the rgb
combination so that completes uh the css
file for the search bar and we obviously
now need to go and
get the code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search file first thing let's go and
import react from
react next thing we would want to do is
import
the search bar dot
css file then we define a class called
search bar which extends
react dot
component we define our constructor and
we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we just need one variable here
which is the term to search for in the
search bar and then let's say this dot
will define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot
search so that's the search function and
we'll have it bind to this
then we've got this dot
handle
enter so the moment we enter into that
search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot set state and for the
term
we will use the event keyword we will
get
the value that is there inside that text
box the moment the search term the user
has entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update the local property props dot
on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which
uh we're also going to pass the system
define event keyword so if there's any
data flowing along with the event we are
interested in it in this case the data
is the key code that the user is
pressing and if it is 13 that indicates
that's the ascii key code for the enter
button so if the enter is hit then the
user is completed entering the search
criteria and we need to start searching
and that's where we write our render
method that's going to render the html
view and we return the complete view
here so that's the view now that we want
to return let's say diff class name
equal to search bar then on the input
text box
we will use placeholder equal to enter
song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change
on the on change event the moment the
term changes we connect that to handle
term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i have to put up here
so in the render function uh we're going
to return a value i shouldn't forget to
export the search bar okay so that's uh
what i want to export so we've exported
that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button tag within the button tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us the html that we've specified okay
we dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions
that we
are actually written
so two things we've completed now
uh in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks delete
removing tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
that we are creating and that's how the
entire application is now structured so
and that's the core
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is
the track component that will manage
individual tracks so a new folder a new
file called track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us so let's start with
dot track we would say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba
to 56 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes uh when we write up the
html view we'll add a padding here of
0.5 we'll set up a font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.20
s
order of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgba
000 color ash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265 2 6 5 5 is the last
paragraph so that's the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center
and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's uh track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we'll
need a margin bottom of 0.22
rpm finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of
0.83 rem and a font weight of 300 and a
color as well that we'll add so let's
add up a color here rgba 2 6 256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css and let's move to the
track and we'll move into the javascript
file so let's move into so let me take
what we added in the search bar i'll go
to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor
this will change to add track so add
track change this to add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this
and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh
this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop start on remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove we'll add up another
function called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is
remove if this dot props dot is
removable so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added via
this render action function and this dot
remove track is what it's going to map
to let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track and we will terminate this
here so now the render action uh let's
also have the return here and we just
add up the button and this is going to
add track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic uh in
nature so we have two buttons that are
going to be added this button with a
hyphen is going to remove the track this
button uh with a plus sign is going to
add the track and you can actually see
how simply it was done in a render
action function so the render action
function actually helped
with uh checking that if uh
on the value of the props and if the
user
depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div here
is going to be
track dash information within it we'll
add h3 we'll bind to this dot props dot
track dot name so the name of the track
is going to get bound here then in the
paragraph we will find to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot algo so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe an iframe
allows us to
very easily inject some content into the
page within a small embedded window the
source parameter of the frame is going
to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash
embed slash track and close this so
that's the spotify stream that we're
going to connect to and this dot props
dot track dot id so that's the track id
the width is going to be 300 the height
parameter this the height parameter is
going to be 80 of the iframe and
the frame order is going to be zero and
the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method
which will actually give us plus minus
button to add and remove a
new element okay and that's uh what we
can actually go and add up there so
let's check now whether uh all that
we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good uh in terms of the
track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track list
css
and it's going to have
track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now
which we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much
so let's just say track list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need
in the css so let me add this in the css
file save this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we
also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks individual tracks
so we want to get this from track slash
track and we'll define class track list
which is going to go and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list
and we'll find to this dot props dot
tracks dot
map create a temporary variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to bind to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be
track dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on ad defined so that's
what we'll connect to we add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove will do this
dot prop start on remove so that's for
the track removal and
so we've got our track list
uh oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export so we'll
have to go and export the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track lists and let's move on
to the next component now so we've got
app which is root we've got the search
bar that takes care of entering the
search criteria we've got individual
tracks that are searched and returned
and we've got a track list that manages
a set of track records so the track is
more relevant to the playlist and then
we've got the search results also to
manage once we search for some set of
tracks so we'll add a new folder which
manages search results
and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we'll say search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels
we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
23 23 0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of zero for pixels to
to pixels
ash
and then uh let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and mozart are the constants specific to
mozilla and chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search
results
width is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of 2
okay so
we're going to add the hyphen so it's
hyphen webkit scroll bar 0 pixel width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with uh the css i need to get
to the uh js file now let's move to the
search results
js file
and that's where we will now have to go
and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list
add it up here this would be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track list this would be track list
and i'm just going to return class name
will also be search results so that's
the component and this is going to
export out search results so it's
accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results let's go and create track list
with a set of tracks and we will bind it
to this dot props dot search results and
on the on add we're going to bind to
this dot props dot on add so we already
have that so that
basically completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need
to add up to the playlist and i'm just
going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's uh just the css
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css uh let me get uh
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather
let me get this and add it out here
we'll make some small changes this is
going to be playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change
and that's exactly the function that we
will need to write code for so that's
the event
and this dot props
dot on name change that's when we'll say
event dot
target dot value so we get the updated
playlist name
coming to the render we now need the
input
is going to be on change equal to
this dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got
track list so track list is what i will
add the tracks i'm going to bind to this
dot props dot playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll bind that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we need to uh do a quick lookup
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in
and create an id it takes us to our
dashboard
that's where we can create a sample
application
the name of the application will be
musical file okay and uh we'll say that
we are building uh some kind of desktop
app for example for which we want to uh
connect this to and we'll also need to
provide so we'll say next
refresh the dashboard so it's uh
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique so i'll just copy that up let me
come up to my application under the
source folder i'm going to add a new
folder
called util and under that a new file
called spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at uh the source of that as we
go through the demo the next variable
that we'll create is the redirect url or
let's call it redirect uri and that will
equate to localhost colon3000 which is
the port and we'll create another
variable called the access token let's
also create another constant variable
called spotify and this will work like a
function expression so we'll equate it
to a function called get access token
and we will say if access token is true
then return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot href dot
match
and we will say this is equal to access
token which will be equal to and we will
keep a regex expression to do a pattern
match ampersand so that we can actually
get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence uh the pattern match is crucial
here another constant
variable called expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another edge
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case the access
token should be equal to access token
match of one then we create a variable
called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say
window.settimeout
and we are going to say access token
equal to comma expires in multiplied by
thousand then we will say window dot
history dot push state and we will say
access token we pass the second
parameter as null the last parameter as
slash and close this and we will return
access token else
we will say const access
url equal to
https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id
ampersand response type equal to token
ampersand scope equal to playlist dash
modify so we're actually building the
url that will now get generated so we'll
say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant
access token equal to spotify dot get
access token so we get a reference to
the same access token return we call the
fetch function and we're going to pass
https
api dot spotify.com
slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the pairer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response
and then we will say
return response dot json after that
another 10 block so we'll now say json
response and if
not
json response dot tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return json response dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as
a variable with a lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary json object
with id and that's where we want to
associate track dot id that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artists of zero dot name the
album is going to be track dot album dot
name and the uri we will equate track
dot url so that completes uh this block
will open the next and we this will be
the save playlist which will take the
name and the track uris and here we will
check if not
name or
not track uris dot len in that case we
simply return out of the code and then
we declare a constant variable called
access token which will be equal to
spotify dot get access token so we get a
reference to the access token we then
declare headers
authorization bearer is going to be
dollar access token and we'll create a
user id and now we will return the fetch
result where we will pass https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers will
be the header information then we call
the then function declare response as a
variable use the lambda expression and
access response dot json we use the then
block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to json
response dot id and then we return fetch
https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1
slash users slash taller of user id
slash
playlist so this is how we've
constructed
the urls manually here we will say
assign headers to the headers variable
we will assign method as post so the
data is sent as part of the body and not
as part of the url and as the body we
will say json.stringify
to convert this parameter name and then
we will generate a response variable to
response.json and then we'll create json
response with the lambda operation we'll
create a constant playlist id which is
equal to json response dot id we will
return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash
playlist slash dollar again we are
constructing the url so playlist id will
be replaced here then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers variable we constant headers and
this
close here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method
is going to be post and the body is
going to be json dot stringify
uris
track uris
and we close this we close this block we
close this block and we close this block
so that completes our code of course one
more thing we'll have to do which is
export this class out so export default
spotify and that completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is uh the client id that we'll
have to exactly match so i'll copy this
client id and provide it here so that's
the client id uh that we actually need
and we could also store it
out here
so that's the uh client id and that's
the redirect url that we've also defined
there and we just create an access token
if here access token is true we return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match from uh uh the moment we try and
connect with this particular url and you
can look here that this is the access
url that we are trying to connect with
okay with the client id and post fixed
with the redirect url right and then
i've got a simple search function which
returns an observable so we try to fetch
data using the search term that we
provided okay we try to fetch data using
the search term provided if we are
successful we get a response of the data
and accordingly we'll iterate over the
json response and get a list of tracks
out of it and do a mapping of this json
object to the track id name artist
information album name etc and here uh
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist and i've got search so
these are the two functions which will
go and connect to the spotify service
by using this client id
and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and bring
out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000 let's give it time to
run and that's the app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i am just going to
search for an artist
and we click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says uh that i need to agree to the
terms and conditions and i've just
agreed to that so the very fact that it
actually uh gave us
a confirmation link uh the moment we
tried to connect and execute our
application uh that's proof enough that
it actually went and
it to the
service there and try to return a value
to us so this is what we did we just
added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
if i go back to my dashboard of my
musical file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully connected out here now i'll
have to log in to so this was the
development app that we actually created
on the developers portal of spotify now
we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist
that just got added right and there were
four songs that i'd actually added to
the playlist and you can see here those
four songs have got added out here okay
so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist the playlist has got
generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity uh that we
successfully created with this react app
and the core concept of the react app
was breaking it down into components
which is the search component then we
created the track component we created
the track list to maintain a list of
tracks uh then we created the search
results which will generate a list of
results which further contains a track
list and this is the embedded iframe
which gave us the response which is
scrollable here and you can see that the
iframes we created allowed us to scroll
this uh with this embedded web page
inside the iframe container so with that
i hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be implemented on
the page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole
so this is your host amarjeet and i'll
be taking you once again to the similar
tour of angular
and you know it very well previously we
have developed a lot of projects in
angular and this time also we will like
to make sure that we offer you some very
consistent project this time where it'll
help you to connect all the dots of
whatever you've learned in an angular so
this particular session will be more
specific towards the project so stay
tuned with me because this time we'll be
offering you a lot of beautiful gui
which can combine together
to understand how angular can be best
suitable for the front-end application
and to make it happen you understand
like in this particular project we'll be
having a basic angular setup ready so
you know it very well to develop an
angular application we have used a
similar technique called
downloading the angular cli version and
we have used ngnu and the name of the
project is project and this particular
project does nothing has only one single
component name called app as you can see
it right now here
under the src you have got app folder
appcomponent.html
and here you see appcomponent.ts
so that is one of the very very basic
component angular can hold in
so
this edge table contains a very simple
message called welcome and component.ts
contains nothing special it is just
holding one title
and
app.module.ts if you see it contains
nothing special whatever it comes as a
predefined preloaded it contains only
those particular type of modules and in
my
app.module.ts sorry
yeah if you talk about call package.json
inside my package.json we have some
additional dependency added
which i will tell you like what
dependencies are part of angular which
comes as a preloaded are by default
available
now you can see here
animation compiler core forms localized
these are all by default are there a
part of that we have also taken
this bootstrap as an additional
dependency so we talk about call ng
bootstrap
okay which is the additional dependency
we have taken bootstrap jquery oper.js
rxjs which anyways comes by default and
here
these dependencies will be playing
additional role during your development
time
okay rest everything gonna be remain
same as it is but yes these additional
dependencies like in jquery poker and
your save ts lib
and you talk about like in bootstrap
okay jquery these libraries are
additional to those the one which comes
as a by default
okay so once you have those additional
dependencies added into your project do
not forget that in your angular.json
you need to have
additional declarations to be get added
okay as you can see now under the
scripts part
okay under the styles part you see the
under the styles we have kept our
bootstrap.min.css
and under the scripts we have kept all
those necessary
dependencies with regards to our js
called demo
chart pie chart pie demo you talk about
bootstrap you talk about jquery so these
are the additional dependencies we have
kept under the scripts part which is
here under your wrangler.json
okay and under the styles we have got
bootstrap through which we can directly
include these bootstrap related stuff
directly into my project
so that would be
the first thing which will start with
okay so
if i want to start my application i will
certainly say npm space start let me say
npm space
start
it is launching my application
okay please use sudo
now it is launching
and under the port number 4200 my
application will be starting up now it
is saying port maybe this application is
ready somewhere
so
let me check if it is available
okay so application is already running
so inside my 4200 if i try to run i can
see this by default message welcome
appears so that's the only thing with
regards to your project so nothing fancy
it is just a basic stuff your
application have some basic set of
dependencies added and along with this
uh you have some
new dependencies and you just you say
npm space start and under the localhost
4200 your project will get ready okay so
in my previous example you remember like
we have created and
done with our basic setup and now it's
time for us to go back and create some
new component into my project
now what is the first component i'm
looking forward for that is called
navbar for creating a navigation so
inside this first of all i want to open
the new one
okay so i want to say ng space g space c
space
nav bar
so let the new component get ready okay
so we have about never component ready
with me
so this is what my navbar is and inside
the snap bar i want to add some
additional dependencies inside my html
okay
so here
i may have lot of tags associated with
me
but here i want to start with my body
tag
okay so this is what i want to start
with my body tag
okay and here onwards we want to start
all my development so within my body tag
i will be writing lot of other tags too
but first of all let me try to have some
additional dependencies to get added
here
so i want to add the div
and here
i would like to have some additional
dependencies to be get added as you can
see right now it is for jquery it is for
your bootstrap it is a scripts okay this
is for
charts this is for chart areas data
tables so these dependencies are very
much required in order to start your
basic development
okay and i want to continue developing
this example by adding some new logic
one by one
okay now what logic i want to add it now
so i will be using bootstrap as a basic
code
okay so first of all i want to use the
body
with some body
class equal to i want to give this name
called sb hyphen
nav
hyphen fixed
that is actually the bootstrap class
which we're associating with here
and uh here after that
we'll be starting with my div tag
so after body
here see this is the sb hyphen nav
hyphen fix which we have used now i'll
be using some nav tag now
and inside my nav tag i want to say
class
equal to
sb
hyphen
uh top nav
space
nav bar
nava hyphen
expand
okay space nav bar
hyphen we want to use the dark theme so
i'll be using
navbar hyphen dark and space bg
hyphen
dark
so this is the first thing we are using
it now now inside my nav
okay we want to use few more important
details like i'm saying like anchor
okay so with this anchor i want to say
a
before hdf we want to say class
equal to navbar
never hyphen brand
okay space nav bar
or else we can say href
we can use this
just add this single quotation and just
say href hr is equal to
index.html to go back
and after this we'll be also using
uh this img tag also so we just use this
img
src will be using some logo
okay which will be there under the
assets
okay under the assets i'll be having
logo dot
png
okay and we would like to also
uh say some controlling this some width
and height so we just use width equal to
what 80 percent
okay and we want to use
height
equal to 120 percent
so where's 80 percent height 120 percent
alt
is maybe something optional you want to
give it i just want to leave it now we
do not want to give art as an
alternative
and if you also want to give style
so i say style
equal to now i say padding
hyphen top
colon
here i say
10 pixels
okay that's it
so that's where exactly the main logic
is let me try to bring this back
okay and here the anchor tag is closed
after this i will be using my
button diagram
with this button we want to add some
class
class equal to btn
space btn
iphone
link
followed by btn
hyphen sm because i want to have a small
size button and i want to say order
iphone one
space
order
iphone
lg
hyphen 0
okay
followed by id
equal to
sidebar toggle
what i'm saying sidebar toggle and after
that some more new properties like in h
ref i do not want to go anywhere so i'm
just saying
hrf equal to what
hash
in the single quotes
like this
okay and that's it
so within this button
i would like to offer
some i class so here i say i class
i
class
equal to
uh
okay fasfa hyphen bars
okay this is a special class available
and
that's it
which is there
now here's the eye class is getting
close and here the button is getting
close now
okay so this is the first part of my
code now
okay now we talk about call navigation
or nav bar search so here i'm starting
with my
never
search
okay so inside my navbar search we would
like to offer some more new number of
fields so called form
okay so i start with my form
now with this form
i
may not say action for a time being so
i'm just removing this action from this
instead we are saying form class
equal to
d
d hyphen
none
space md
hyphen
inline
okay hyphen block
hyphen
block
okay so md hyphen inline iphone block
after that you have to suggest form
hyphen
and here you see inline because i want
to go ahead with the inline form
and also ml
hyphen auto
space mr hyphen 0
space mr iphone md
hyphen
my iphone
displays my hyphen md
hyphen 0
so this is what all about our form but
within this form is not yet closed it is
just a first portion of the form plus
along with this will be also offering
the div class so we just use div
here i say
class equal to
input hyphen
group
input hyphen group
and
now inside this input action group i
want to use input class
input type equal to text
and here i say class
input
class equal to
form
hyphen
control
for hyphen control we would like to add
few more classes here first it is form
control
type equal to what type it is a type
text and now we say
placeholder equal to
search
for
okay this is the property for me
but i want to use it
and
a part of that
search for we're giving it so since it
is giving so we don't need to give
double quotes
search for us single quotes is okay now
and now
area
hyphen
level equal to
search
one second let me try to make it
okay search here and
followed by a few more properties so the
first property i'm trying to use it a
part of this area search we say area
hyphen
okay described by and here we give the
value called basic iphone
hyphen
add-on to
okay so this is how we are trying to add
it now
after this what next
after this we would like to use another
div tag now
div
and here we say
class
equal to
inside this class we may offer few more
details
okay like i can see input group
input iphone
hyphen group
iphone
append
okay that is a div class and inside this
dip class
i would like to use also another button
here we say
class equal to
vtn space btn hyphen
primary okay type equal to what it is a
button
so
that's it
and after that within this button i
would like to use i
class
equal to
fs space fa hyphen
search
okay that's it so this is how we are
making it
first and now we'll be going ahead with
the next level okay so let's get started
with the next point now so we have
finished our div and dip form now let me
try to organize it properly
okay
now the div div and this part is getting
close and now we would like to talk
about our network part
okay so here
i'm starting with the nav point so here
excellent tree
and here i give the name for never
just to tell you like this would be the
nava related
stuff
here i'll start with my url tag now so
inside my ul i say you will space
class equal to
navbar
okay so we have a call navbar hyphen
nav
okay space ml
hyphen
auto
space ml hyphen
md
iphone 0
so that is for my ul so within this ul
i'll be having
some ally class also so we have got li
within this li i'm saying
class equal to
now what are the details i want i say
now iphone
item
okay nav hyphen i item space
drop down
okay so now hyphen item space what a
drop down log
now within this
li tag okay i want to use lot of other
tags too
so first tag i'm using this is called
anchor tag
okay
so
in this anchor tag we want to say a
and followed by
class equal to
well i'm saying nav hyphen
link
followed by drop down
hyphen toggle
okay after this space id
equal to
user
drop down
okay add equal to what user drop down
href
equal to we just make it as just a hash
because i'm not taking anywhere
after this hash we say roll
equal to
button so role will be a button type
and the job doesn't get over here we
also have some option called
data hyphen
toggle
okay data hyphen toggle equal to drop
down
equal to drop down
space we also want to use some area
has pop-up
okay you can see there's a property
called idiot has pop-up so i just said
true
yes exactly it does have
and we also want to say area hyphen
expanded
you see now area hyphen expanded we're
also saying
false
a part of that
we also want to use some image within
this
so
image
in this image we want to say src
src will be entered
okay
assets under the assets it will be under
id
dot
png this is already sorry jpg
there's already one value available
inside this id png alt we don't want it
as of now
if you want you can add it otherwise i'm
just leaving it blank i'm just using
this option called style equal to
now
border hyphen
hyphen radius
okay this hyphen border it is how much
you want to give i'm saying 50 percent
that is the css style
okay and followed by width
how much weight you're giving it i'm
saying 50 pixels
pixels
okay
that's the whole idea for this
now the anchor tag is getting closed
okay so here the anchor tag is closed
after the acne tag is closed we would
like to give another tip class now for
the drop down
so we say
this div class will have some of the set
of properties which is available i say
div
class equal to
drop down
okay iphone menu
and
followed by
iphone
menu
hyphen
right
okay
and
followed by we want to use area
area
hyphen
you can see this option called label by
okay equal to give the option name
called user
drop down i'm just giving the value user
drop down
value has been given
now within this div tag itself will be
adding some new more values
what those values will be i am saying
anchor tag
class equal to
now that is an anchor tag
class
equal to drop down
drop down hyphen item
okay space
href
equal to
hash
href equal to what hash
we're giving the value call what
settings
okay now i just copy this line
okay and
let's have only two for a time being so
drop down hyphen item hdf settings and
we give it a give one more option that
is called activity log
activity
log
that's the value
for activity log
okay anchor tag is getting close now
here after that we use another tab tag
here
it's called nested tip tag
okay so in this div tag we want to use
class
equal to drop down hyphen item
drop down hyphen
item
and
i would say by the dropping iphone
divider
drop down
hyphen divided as a value and
in the same div tag
this div tag is getting closed here and
we're using one more okay
and class
equal to drop down hyphen
item
dropdown item item hrx equal to
give the value the one which you want to
give it i'm saying hash
okay
it's difficult to what hash
let me close this
yeah hdf equal to hash and
we just use router link
equal to as you know it very well
in typical navigation we always use the
router link rather than normal href
and here we are giving the name call
what login
okay and here we can use
router link active equal to
active
okay
and here we get the name called logout
log
[Music]
out
okay so that's the value which we are
giving it now anchor tag is closed and
here the div tag is closed li ul and nav
so let me organize it
this one
and lab tag
let me format this
okay so that's what my file is
okay so let's continue to this so we
have created the value till now and we
want to start with this div diagonal
now with this dev tag
we would like to have few more classes
added now
we say div id equal to
we can just give the name called layout
site info
layout sidenav
so this is the first value we are taking
it now
with this layout side now
a part of this would like to use another
div tag now
and inside this div we would like to
offer the id
equal to
layout
site nav
whatever name we have used it
underscore now
that is a
second div type we have it now
now within this we want to use the nav
okay with this snap we want to say plus
equal to
sb
hyphen sidenav
sidenav
hyphen
menu
that value we are passing it to this
okay that is for
sb hyphen side net view
or along with this rather than menu i
can have another option with me to make
it even more better sb hyphen sidenav
space
accordion
okay
so
according we're going to give you the
kind of flipping type of moment one
after another sp hyphen
side now
sb iphone sidenav hyphen
dock
and space id equal to
side neverword
side
nav
accordion
so this value we are using it now with
this nav
so within this snap
we would like to bring another div class
now
by saying live
and inside this div we will say class
equal to
i would say sp
hyphen side nav
hyphen
menu
okay
now within this div tag we want to use
another dev diagram
so you might be thinking so many tip tag
is that is why we want to make it more
organized we said dev
class
equal to
nav
okay now within this div tag we would
like to use another dive
here we want to say sp hyphen
sp iphone site name
hyphen menu
hyphen heading
site name iphone menu hyphen heading
okay and in this we just giving the
value called
code this is the value of this
okay so this is what for the first jet
tag
now within this div tag
when this step tag is closed we want to
use the anchor tag now
a
class equal to
nav hyphen
link
okay nav hyphen link followed by
hdf equal to give the name called
index dot
html
so this is your href one second
h f equal to index dot html
now now within this anchor tag we want
to use the div tag now
okay and in this div we would like to
say class
equal to
uh sp hyphen
nav hyphen link
hyphen icon
so div class equal to sp hyphen nav
hyphen link hyphen icon this is a class
of my div time right now
okay
now
this particular
class inside this we want to use
the
i class something i
plus equal to fs
space fa
hyphen
tachometer
tachometer hyphen alt
okay
and we are closing this i tag is getting
close the tip tag is getting close
okay and within this i'm giving the
value call what dashboard
okay
so a class equal to
giving this call
nav link
and hdf equal to index dot
html and here we have the div tag which
is
getting close now and here the anchor
tag is closed
and after the anchor tag is closed we
can use few more div tags inside this
okay let's see about which of the div
tags are now left with here we start
another div tag
now inside this div we say class equal
to
sb
hyphen
side nav
okay sb hyphen site name iphone menu
hyphen heading
hyphen heading and now we want to use
one tool name called interface
so here we have a called dev diagram
after this we would like to use another
anchor tag
okay and now with this anchor tag we
want to say class
equal to
now
as we know it very well we have given
this call menu heading so we get nav
link collapse so we say nav
hyphen link
space
collapse
okay so that is a
class which we are using it now with my
anchor tag
okay collapsed after that we are saying
href
equal to hash
okay h f equal to what hash and
data hyphen
toggle
equal to
collapse
so that's the value we are giving it to
my data toggle now
after that we're giving some more values
here
one where we are giving is called data
target
yeah data target equal to
here we're giving this id
by saying collapse layout
collapse layouts
there is a daily target and we just want
to say area
hyphen expanded
area hyphen expanded equal to
false
and one more property i want to give it
area hyphen controls
area
hyphen
controls
okay
equal to collapse layout
collapse layouts
one second let me try to add it here
and edit it here
collapse layouts
okay so anchor tag is there so within my
anchor tag where it is getting closed i
just want to give
one more
dev tag inside this
yeah so here we have got
okay so within this div tag
we want to give some additional property
to this div
so
we know it very well what type of data
is we are talking about so we set if
class
equal to
sp
hyphen nav link
sb hyphen
nav link
okay hyphen icon
there is another class we are using it
now
and uh
sorry
sb hyphen nav hyphen link
that the first property we have taken
let me close this
and uh
okay so sb hyphen nav hyphen link
and
a part of this you can just use hyphen
icon
iphone
okay within this
uh i can use
i class
so here i'm using i
class equal to
so which class you want to use i'm
saying fs
space fa hyphen
angle
okay
hyphen dom
so this is your i class which we are
defining it right now
okay closing this so i tag is getting
close along with the div tag now
okay and anchor tag is anyways getting
closed
okay anchor tag is getting close here so
inside this we would like to give if the
div tag is getting close we want to give
home
anywhere which you want to give so we're
giving what over here
and this is where it's getting
close right now
okay
so after the div tag is getting closed
we're using this
and
so later on we can go back and try to
implement more ideas okay so we have
finished till one point of
areas now we would like to go back and
start working with the row level now
so now here with my application we want
to use
the another div tag now
so within this div tag we want to use
some classes we said
space
class equal to
row
okay after this i use one more div tag
and in this div tag we want to use one
more property here called
[Music]
class equal to call
hyphen excel
hyphen six
so six columns layout we are trying to
add it now here we are trying to say div
and with this div we say class
equal to
now see the properties now do class
equal we're using card
space
mb hyphen 4
card space mb hyphen 4 we're using this
property
now after that we would like to use
another div tag
with using div
plus equal to
header
i would rather say card hyphen header i
will say
card hyphen header so this div class
and inside this we want to say i
i
class equal to
some addition
declaration i'm saying fs space
fa hyphen
chart
hyphen
area
space mr hyphen 1
so
closing this so i tag is getting closed
here we're going to give the value name
called weekly analysis
weekly
weekly analysis okay so with this div
tag it is getting closed i want to bring
another tip tag inside this
now with this div tag
we want to write another class here
that is known as call class equal to
card hyphen body
so we want to give class equal to card
hyphen
class equal to
card hyphen
body
okay
and
this class equal to card acts and body
we want to bring
another thing inside this that is called
img
equal to now here
from the assets we want to use
area
chart
area chart dot
png so that location we want to use it
now followed by
width equal to 100
okay
and
height
equal to 280
okay and here the tip tag is getting
closed
okay
so we're talking about this dev tag and
there's another tip tag is getting close
below this the third div tag is also
getting close now
okay so we totally have three div tag is
getting close and we would like to use
another tab diagonal
we want to set them
class equal to once again
call hyphen
xs
excel
hyphen 6
so six columns layout we are talking
about
and after that we say div class
div class
equal to card
space mb iphone 4
okay dev classical card space mb hyphen
4 and again we use another div tag
okay and inside this div we say class
equal to
header
name class equal to what
header rather i would say card hyphen
header
card hyphen header now
now within this dev tag we want to use
another i class
yeah so within this card hyphen header
we want to use the
another
chart so as we've already seen we have
used this uh
assets
hyphen chart area.chat png in a similar
way we would like to use the same
technique now for the monthly report
also okay so
we have a call called sn6 card mp4
okay we're using what card header so
in this
the way we have used weekly analysis
i just copy this the same
okay and i pasted it here
okay and here what i try to offer
not weekly analysis i would rather offer
monthly report
okay monthly report and after the div
title is close card body and now we talk
about call bar chart.png
bar chart dot png width equal to 100
percent
the div tag is getting closed here
so this is how we're trying to use it
now
so just like that we can keep on using
some another properties too
now
here
we want to use one more table
okay in this div tag
we feel class
equal to
now let's provide another property here
so we said deb class equal to card
okay space mb
iphone
and other details too
we were on this position called card
hyphen mv hyphen force
and followed to this we want to use
another tip tag
by saying div class equal to card hyphen
header div
class equal to
card hyphen
header
so that is another div class we are
using it now so inside this div class we
want to use another i
i
class
equal to
here i'm using once again fs
space fa
hyphen
table
space
mr
hyphen one
okay that's the position we are using it
right now
okay
and after this i tag here we define this
option name called employee data
employee
data
so here the div tag is getting closed
okay so
now our three properties we have taken
it now weekly monthly report
employee data now we would like to
create a table now
so whatever we are looking forward for
let's start we are saying div
class equal to
card hyphen
body
okay now within this div class equal to
called hyphen body we are using another
tab tag here now
okay and inside this dev tag will say
class equal to
table hyphen
responsive so we want to use table
hyphen responsive
fine now after this we want to create a
table
okay within this table
okay we would like to create table
headed multiple things but let me add
some classes here i'm saying table
class equal to we want to use table
space table
hyphen border
[Music]
border and after that we use id equal to
just give the name called data table
after this data table we say width
equal to 100
hundred percent and also we want to use
cell spacing
cell
spacing
so some spacing we are giving equal to
zero
that is for my table and now inside this
table i can have
table head
okay under the table head i will be
using tr
so tr and we should be having
ph which is called table heading
so we're giving the first property
yeah so here i give name like this i
just copy this
and take few more property
name position
here we give call office
then age
then we give start date
and one more
and that is called salary
so these are part of table heading
tr is closed the head is closed now we
would like to use t body
we would like to use keyboard you know
inside the t body we want to use tr
which is your table row under this we
want to use what
td that is called a table data so here
we can give the name
so the first value we are giving is
called tiger
nexon let me copy
and paste it
so that is the first value second is
known for position so we are saying
system architect
okay system architect that is what my
table data
next we're looking forward for office
we're giving the office name called
edinburgh
next it is asking for
your age let's give the age call
61.
next is asking for the start date so we
just give
slash
04 slash 25 and yet we can give it
last which is asking for the salary and
just say
dollar
any random value i've given it now
okay so this is the first stable row is
basically closed
like that we can have multiple records
with me
i copy this
and have another
and have another so as my number of
records you want you can basically have
it now
okay let me quickly change the name
this value called content
next value which we have it is called
tokyo
age
okay same
and here we can give
okay
and here you can change the values later
on if you want but for the display
purpose
it's okay
okay so here
the multiple things are getting closed
your tea body is getting close
your table is getting closed
your div tag is getting close your div
tag is getting closed and
after this we have got one more
that is the other
okay after closing the last dip tag we
would like to also close
the main
okay after this main
uh we would like to start working with
this photo part now
in this
footer we would like to add some new
classes here i'm saying class equal to
py
iphone 4
space bg hyphen
light space empty
hyphen
auto
okay
followed by we can use the another div
tag
and inside this div we can use
class equal to
container hyphen fluid
now there's another div tag
okay inside this div we want to use what
class
equal to
d hyphen flex
okay space
align hyphen
items hyphen
center space
justify
hyphen content
hyphen between
space
small
okay now inside this div we would like
to use another div
reset div
class
equal to text mounted
text
hyphen
muted
okay and we would like to
offer
here let's go copyright
copyright
okay and
copy
okay
space
give the name
dot
simply here or else
like this okay so div tag is getting
closed here now after that you can use
hlf
equal to you can just give hash
okay
and now you can give the value call what
privacy policy
okay and here in private sequence you
can just give
ampersand
okay
and
and after this again href
so after this
we can use but first anchor tag is
getting closed here after this privacy
policy okay so
now other hrefs here hash
rather than privacy policy i'm gonna
give terms
okay in terms
give space
okay
conditions
okay terms and conditions
you don't need this numb
and that's it so dev tube tip
photo is also getting closed dev tag is
also getting closed
so
photographs also and
there's another div tag is getting
closed and after that
another day will be included
okay
and that's it body will be closed post
that
okay so there are a lot of space let me
try to remove
that's it so now let me format it
let's see what this is always critical
fusion so guys our navbar component is
ready and after that we go back and try
to add few more things into my code now
we're going to create a few more
components into my code so first
component a part of this
what we have seen i'm going to create
one more component name called toggle so
ng space g space c
space
toggle
okay a part of that we want to create
few more components here there is one
routes
so ng space g space c space
okay
so this component is ready along with
this
as we know it very well
like there are certain components which
we have created we also would like to
create few more components into my
application
okay by saying
ng
space g space c
space uh
[Music]
let's see
so under the routes we have got what
charts is another component which we
have seen now
okay now in a similar way i would like
to create one more component under the
routes and that is for login
component is ready along with this login
we would like to create a register
and
along with this we would like to also go
back and create one more component here
that is called
password
so charts login register password
so four components are ready now and
they're all inside what they're all
inside under the roots
okay so these all components are now
ready with me and we'll be basically
making all those components
associated inside my routes part
clear now so which component used what
that we have to basically consider it
now
so since they're all of the components
so under my
app.routing.module.ts we have to
basically provide a routing here now so
here we know calls for routes equal to
blank so let me try to say
path
okay earth colon
if nothing is being given so the by
default component will be what
component
will be
nav bar
component
so this network components automatically
comes up here after that
if
path is of what
is static
component
is what
toggle component
okay and here we are saying
path match
colon
okay
along with this we're giving one more
path
colon login
so here
component
colon login component
i'm going to put comma
concurrency small
okay
now like this next we talk about call
path
colon
register
okay and here
component colon
register component
now let's talk about what path colon
what
change
password
so here
we say
component
comma
component colon
which command we are trying to say
password component
also component next
we want to say path
colon
charts
then
component column
charge component so these are the
components are now available to me so
these components are now all set and
later on we'll be combining all the
files together
in my system one by one
okay everybody so our all components are
now all ready so you see like we have
got navbar
which contains all the necessary
tags whichever is required for my
application
here we have a basically the login and
this login.component.html
actually contains all the relative part
which is
related to your login like you can talk
about call
email you talk about call password you
have a call remember me and forgot
password these type of details are
available inside your
logincomponent.html now so this is
basically the code okay which contains
your login related stuffs now
so it contains only few properties like
you talk about like email address
it contains what a password and only the
buttons through which user can log in
through
followed by when i see my
password so this
password
file that is called
password.component.html
it contains
the details
regarding to your password so that the
user can
give the password details or in case of
the user has
or want to change the password so we can
give the details like okay you can enter
your email id
address where i can send the password to
you so here
we have this email address we haven't
implemented
your
i would say any kind of
sending the email to your
uh registered email id that logic hasn't
been implemented but it's just for the
demo like how exactly you can bring this
password
uh forgot condition inside your system
now so this is what the password and
here we have a link for the login and
here we have all registration
followed by if you think about call
register register contains that
register.component.html
and here if you see there are few
details which are expecting from the
user like in first name last name email
password confirm password so these are
the quick fields which i'm expecting
from the user to enter
and here it's a button for
you know
confirming a password and this is what
exactly the links which are available
for the login
okay and for the login.html file so this
is a simple registration form which is
available to me
and that is last which is available for
me for that for me that is called
toggling part
in toggle part we are just offering
the details with regards to your how in
case if you want to toggle you can
change the settings okay based on
between the settings and activity
okay so these are the links which are
available through which you can change
all different type of toggling part
whether you would like to enable or not
enable
this is something which is related to
your page in case if you click on that
link so 401 page 404 page 500 page which
will be available to us
now let's try to run the code and check
how the final application really looks
like
okay so now i'm trying to run my
application
by
same
npm space start once again
okay
and now i'm trying to say
game space start
let the project start now
you will see how it really looks like it
so it is compiling all the files
okay and finally let's try to execute
localhost 4200
let me see what is an issue right now
okay let me check meanwhile try to run
it run it again
okay now i finally uh i'm into my
current project right now so it was the
wrong location it was available so i
just like to say npm space start and let
the project run
so project is picking up till the time i
say localhost photodouble zero
and beautiful guys this is how exactly
projects really looks like it
isn't is an amazing right now
see how beautiful your project really
looks like it
this is what exactly the dashboard you
have it and this is the nav bar which is
available to you
getting it now see how better and
beautiful it looks and organize so this
is like in real time dashboard which is
available where you can see the bird
days you have it
you talk about
you know company announcement
quick links these are all basically
available these are the charts which you
can see can give some dummy values and
these are the charts will be really
available to you
so this is how the employee records
which we had it which we are displaying
it right now and this is how exactly the
chart looks like it
so weekly analysis and monthly analysis
this is the dashboard
and here the links are there but they're
all dummy links we haven't made it but
you can certainly make it further
okay you can search for
anything but it is not working right now
because it is just for the display
because nothing more than that
it is a home which you can see written
like in profile
this is like the profile which we have
created
by default the name is called kate adams
uh and this is resignation like an
account it
and like you can talk about like home
under the home you have a profile here
called settings
so nothing is the research in the
settings so it is just a static record
attendance
it will be bringing you back to the same
page we have a call confirmation
travel expenses these are basically the
dummy links which are available we
haven't made it
which you can
see new development
okay part of that you see like profile
we have it settings
account activity if you see we have
called login and register these three
page if you remember we have created it
under this system
so you can see we have a got login we
have a call register we have a call
password
these are you are able to see this now
when you say change password you see
like
how they have given to you they're not
actually working but they're just like a
dummy option and you can see it will be
taking you directly to the sign up
option
okay
now here
in your
settings once again you can look forward
for the login
it works like in
a typical model how it comes
apart of that we also have this
call register
so these are the fields of registration
form
and
you see about activity activity we have
because these pages are available there
are basically dummy pages which we have
created download confirmation so really
it this project really gives you the
kind of sense of
in real time how
your
application angular application can
really make your
ui more attractive which are more
competitive in market so i hope you guys
love this project
so we have developed most of the codes
by our own
except few
which we have taken it from uh
online that is nothing but call uh
especially those images as well as uh
what to say some javascript related
libraries if you see which we are using
it right now here you think about think
about this uh
uh
your
navbar.com.html if you see like these
are the libraries we have taken it from
internet
because certainly we don't type it
because it is taking long time to type
certainly we have taken from internet
and some images also we have taken it
from the internet which are there under
the assets folder too
so if you see under the assets we have a
lot of images like an area chart bar
chart chart so this we have downloaded
from the internet
so hope you guys love this project thank
you very much
and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you